This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. In 1965, Mark Rudd was an 18-year-old freshman at Columbia University in New York. America's military involvement in Vietnam was ramping up. At first, Mark wasn't interested in much beyond his studies, but before long, he was drawn in by the passion of his politically engaged peers. He would later write,
这里是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。1965年，马克·鲁德是纽约哥伦比亚大学的一名18岁大一新生。当时，美国对越南的军事卷入正在加剧。起初，马克对学业之外的事情兴趣不大，但没过多久，他就被那些热心政治的同龄人的激情所吸引。他后来写道：
Over beers or a joint, I'd listen to discussions about China's cultural revolution, then just starting, and to Cuba's seven-year-old revolution. It was thrilling to be with these people who were tapping into something so much bigger than ourselves, something so grand, so historic, remaking the world. By the time he was 20, he had been elected chairman of the Columbia chapter of Students for a Democratic Society, or SDS. In 1968, he led the student occupation of several university buildings. He called his parents, exhilarated. We took a building, he exclaimed. Well, give it back, his father told him.
在喝啤酒或抽大麻时，我会听他们讨论当时刚开始的中国的文化大革命，以及古巴革命七周年的情况。能和这些人在一起真是让人兴奋，他们正在触及某种比我们自身宏大得多、崇高得多、历史意义深远得多、足以重塑世界的事物。到20岁时，他已经被选为争取民主社会学生组织（简称SDS）哥伦比亚大学分会的主席。1968年，他领导了学生占领多所大学建筑的行动。他兴奋地给父母打电话。我们占领了一栋楼，他大声喊道。好吧，把它还回去，他父亲对他说。
But Mark was drawn deeper into radicalism. Along with some friends, he formed a revolutionary band known as the Weather Underground. The group sought to violently overthrow the government and instigated a string of bombings. The violence gave Mark pause, but he felt compelled to continue. I felt like a member of the crew on a speeding train, dimly aware of disaster ahead, but unable to put on the brakes, he would later recall. Decades later, Mark Rudd said he had feelings of guilt and shame about his actions. He told a pair of documentary filmmakers,
但马克越陷越深，走向了激进主义。他和几个朋友组成了一个名为“地下气象员”的革命团伙。该组织企图通过暴力推翻政府，并发动了一系列炸弹袭击。暴力让马克犹豫过，但他感到自己不得不继续下去。他后来回忆道：“我感觉自己就像一辆疾驰火车上的乘务员，隐约意识到前方有灾难，却无法踩下刹车。”几十年后，马克·鲁德表示，他对自己的行为感到内疚和羞耻。他告诉两位纪录片制作者：
these are things that I am not proud of. Few of us become violent revolutionaries like Mark Rudd, but most of us know what it's like to be part of an energized, passionate group. This week on Hidden Brain, we kick off a new series called Emotions 2.0. We start today with a special double-header episode. We look at what happens to our brains when we get caught up in a crowd, and then explore how these ideas shape cultures and societies around the world. The line between different disciplines in the social sciences can be blurry. Anthropologists, psychologists, economists, and sociologists all study human behavior, but
这些事情是我不引以为傲的。我们很少有人会像马克·鲁德那样成为暴力的革命者，但我们大多数人都知道成为一个充满活力、充满激情的群体中的一员是什么感觉。本周的“隐藏大脑”节目，我们开启了一个名为“情绪2.0”的新系列。今天我们从一个特别的双集连播节目开始。我们探讨当人们被卷入人群时，我们的大脑会发生什么，然后探讨这些观点如何塑造世界各地的文化和社会。社会科学中不同学科之间的界限可能是模糊的。人类学家、心理学家、经济学家和 sociologists（社会学家）都在研究人类行为，但
they use different lenses and different terminologies. Our focus on this show is to explore human behavior in daily life. We look at what animates individuals, when they are happy and when they are sad, and how people can bring about change in their lives. At Harvard Business School, the psychologist Amit Goldenberg studies why we feel what we feel, but the lens he uses takes a step back from individual minds to how groups think, feel, and act. Amit Goldenberg, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much. It's great to be here. Amit, I understand that you grew up in an Orthodox Jewish home.
他们使用不同的镜头和不同的术语。我们在本节节目中的重点是探讨日常生活中的人类行为。我们观察是什么在激励个人，他们在什么时候快乐，什么时候悲伤，以及人们如何在生活中带来改变。在哈佛商学院，心理学家阿米特·戈尔登贝格研究我们为什么会有这种感受，但他使用的视角从个人思维退后了一步，转而关注群体是如何思考、感受和行动的。阿米特·戈尔登贝格，欢迎来到“隐藏的大脑”。非常感谢。很高兴来到这里。阿米特，据我了解，你是在一个正统犹太家庭长大的。
One of the most important dates on the calendar was the holiday of Yom Kippur. What did the day signify for you? Yom Kippur was a really special day for us. I remember I used to be scared of that day. I felt that this was a really important day in kind of determining the future or the next year for me, whether it's gonna be a good year or a bad year. And so I wanted to get to that day in the right mindset and in the right way and kind of do the right prayers
日历上最重要的日子之一就是赎罪日。这一天对你来说意味着什么？赎罪日对我们来说是一个非常特殊的日子。我记得我以前很怕那一天。我觉得这真的是非常重要的一天，某种程度上决定了我的未来或接下来的一年，无论是好的一年还是坏的一年。所以我想以正确的心态和正确的方式迎来这一天，并进行正确的祈祷
and kind of get ready in the right way and kind of do the right prayers and kind of get ready in the right way. So you have a vivid memory of fasting for Yom Kippur when you were just 10 years old. Can you paint me a picture of what you did, what you saw, and what you heard that day? Can you paint me a picture of what you did, what you saw and what you heard that day? Yeah. So traditionally, children start to fast when they're 13 after their bar mitzvah, but I really wanted to try. So that was my first big attempt. And the first evening was kind of easy, but already in the morning I was completely weak and I could barely stand.
并在某种程度上以正确的方式做好准备，并在某种程度上以正确的方式进行祈祷，并以正确的方式做好准备。所以你对年仅10岁时斋戒赎罪日有着清晰的记忆。你能给我描绘一下那天你做了什么、看到了什么、听到了什么吗？你能给我描绘一下那天你做了什么、看到了什么、听到了什么吗？可以的。传统上，孩子们在13岁成年礼之后才开始斋戒，但我真的很想尝试一下。所以那是我的第一次重大尝试。第一个晚上还算轻松，但到了早上我已经完全虚弱得几乎站不起来了。
And there's a special prayer which is the heart of that day, which is all about atonement, talks about the decision that God has to make, and so it says, how many shall pass away and how many shall be born? Who shall live and who shall die? Who's by water and who's by fire? And so, I was always anxious about this prayer because it kind of very vividly portrays the future of portrays the future of various people. But there's also something very calming in feeling this anxiety with other people, something very protective. So as a community, we're praying for everyone's kind of verdict, rather than my own personal verdict.
有一个特殊的祈祷是那一天的核心，它全是关于赎罪的，谈到上帝必须做出的决定，所以它说，有多少人将离去，有多少人将出生？谁将生，谁将死？谁死于水，谁死于火？因此，我总是对这段祈祷感到焦虑，因为它非常生动地描绘了各种人的未来。但以这种焦虑与其他人一同感受，也有某种非常平静的东西，某种非常有保护性的东西。因此，作为社区，我们为每个人的某种命运祈祷，而不是仅仅为我个人的命运祈祷。
And I think it's one of the first times that I acknowledge how strong collective experiences could be. So more than a century ago the sociologist Emil Durkheim talked about an idea as people go through things together, they experience something that he called collective effervescence. How is this connected, do you think, to what you felt at age 10? Oh, very much connected. Durkheim is one of the most influential thinkers for me. I don't think it's a coincidence that Durkheim also focused on religious ceremonies, because
我认为这是我第一次意识到集体经历有多么强大。所以一个多世纪前，社会学家埃米尔·迪尔凯姆谈到一个观点：当人们一起经历事情时，他们会体验到他所称的“集体狂热”。你认为这与你10岁时的感受有什么联系？哦，联系非常紧密。迪尔凯姆对我来说是最具影响力的思想家之一。我认为迪尔凯姆也专注于宗教仪式并非巧合，因为
I do think that they represent some of the strongest collective emotional experience. But one thing that was missing, and that became part of my goal as a researcher, was to kind of try to unpack that experience. What does that mean to feel effervescence? There's obviously a sense of togetherness, but there are also very specific processes that are occurring as groups feel emotions together that tend to lead to this feeling of effervescence.
我的确认为它们代表了一些最强烈的集体情感体验。但有一点缺失了，这也成为了我作为研究人员的目标之一，那就是试图剖析那种体验。感受到狂热意味着什么？显然有一种团结感，但当群体共同感受情感时，也会发生非常具体的过程，这些过程往往会导致这种狂热感。
I want to talk about a second example in your life that showed you the power of collective or shared emotions. As a young adult living in Israel, Amit, you became an activist. You often engaged in protests against the policies of the Israeli government. One of these demonstrations took place in a neighborhood of Jerusalem.
我想谈谈你生活中的第二个例子，它向你展示了集体或共享情感的力量。阿米特，作为住在以色列的年轻人，你成了一名活动人士。你经常参与抗议以色列政府政策的活动。其中一次游行发生在耶路撒冷的一个社区。
What was the trigger for the protest and what happened? Yeah, so like many Israelis, I was always conflicted by feeling strong identity to the country that I am at and feeling a strong sense to serve the country, but also feeling very strong negative emotions about some of the policies that are being taken by the Israeli government. And one of the experiences that are the strongest to me is an event that took place in Jerusalem in a Palestinian side of Jerusalem called Shekh Jarrah, where a family of Palestinians were evicted from their homes.
抗议的导火索是什么？发生了什么？是的，所以像许多以色列人一样，我总是充满矛盾：一方面对所在的国家有着强烈的认同感，并有一种强烈的服务国家的使命感；另一方面，对以色列政府采取的一些政策又怀有强烈的负面情绪。对我而言最强烈的经历之一，是2009年8月在耶路撒冷一个被称为谢赫贾拉的巴勒斯坦人聚居区发生的一起事件，当时一个巴勒斯坦家庭被驱逐出他们的家园。
And I remember watching the videos of what's happening in their house a few days after the event, which took place in August 2009, and I was absolutely furious. I can still think about those videos and it makes me angry just to talk about it. And there was nothing I could do about it. There was nothing no one could do about it, I mean, other than demonstrate. And there are already demonstrations about this happening in Jerusalem. I was living at the time at Tel Aviv, and I remember getting a ride to the demonstration, and I just wanted to express kind of rage and anger with other people. What's interesting is when I got
我记得在事件发生几天后——那是在2009年8月——观看他们房子里发生的事情的视频时，我气炸了。我只要一想到那些视频，光是谈论它就让我感到愤怒。对此我无能为力。我的意思是，除了示威游行，没有人能做任何事。耶路撒冷当时已经有关于此事的游行了。我当时住在特拉维夫，我记得搭便车去参加游行，我只是想和其他人一起表达那种狂怒和愤怒。有趣的是，当我到达
there, I realized something very interesting. Yes, there was a lot of rage, and expressing it with other people was a great feeling, but there were also a lot of positive emotions. People were also interacting with each other, laughing and having fun. And I remember thinking that you need to have both in some ways. The possibility to feel anger with other people, and that feels good, but also to normalize the situation so that people will have the energy to keep going. And I came back to demonstrate every Friday for almost a year and it really kept me going.
那里时，我意识到了一件非常有趣的事情。是的，有很多愤怒，和别人一起表达这种愤怒感觉很好，但也有很多积极的情绪。人们也在互相交流、欢笑和享受乐趣。我记得当时想，在某种程度上你需要两者兼顾。既有和别人一起感受愤怒的可能性，这感觉很好，同时也要将局势正常化，这样人们才会有精力和动力继续坚持下去。在将近一年的时间里，我每个星期五都回来参加抗议，这确实让我坚持了下来。
It's clear that what brought you back was not just your feelings about the injustice about what happened, but also the sense that you were among other people who shared your concerns. That's right. One of the unique things about collective emotions is that feeling negative emotions together, even if these emotions that are typically unpleasant at the individual level,
显然，让你回来的不仅是你对所发生的不公的感受，还有那种你与关心同样事情的人在一起的感觉。没错。集体情感的一个独特之处在于，即使这些情感在个人层面通常是不愉快的，但一起感受负面情绪，
doing it with other people feels good. And that's a strong reason for why people join together level, doing it with other people feels good. And that's a strong reason for why people join together to demonstrate and to generate collective action processes. Because despite of the fact that in many cases this is driven by negative experiences, it also feels really good to do it with other people. There was a third moment in your life when you noticed that what you were feeling was closely tied up with what others were feeling.
和别人一起做感觉很好。这也是人们聚在一起示威并产生集体行动过程的强有力原因。因为尽管在很多情况下，这是由负面经历驱动的，但和别人一起做也感觉真的很棒。在你生命中的第三个时刻，你注意到你的感受与别人的感受紧密相连。
You were doing some investigative work on companies and paying close attention to the stock market. Something unusual happened on May 6th, 2010. What kind of work were you doing, Ameet, and what happened that day? Yeah, so I worked as a journalist in Israel and I did some investigative journalism, including work on companies in Israel. And I was hired by an American company to do some analytic work related to the stock markets at around 2010. And so it was the first time that really my personal wellness was connected to the stock market. And for those of you whose job is to look at the stock market all day, you know that the volatility of the market has a huge effect on one's own emotions. What happened on May 6, 2010 is called the flash crash,
你当时在对公司进行一些调查工作，并密切关注股市。2010年5月6日发生了一件不同寻常的事。阿米特，你当时在做什么样的工作，那天发生了什么？是的，我当时在以色列担任记者，做了一些调查性新闻，包括对以色列公司的研究。大约在2010年，我被一家美国公司雇佣，做一些与股市相关的分析工作。所以那是我个人的福祉第一次与股市联系在一起。对于那些工作就是整天盯着股市的人来说，你知道市场的波动对个人的情绪有巨大的影响。2010年5月6日发生的事情被称为闪崩，
and it started at 2.32 PM Eastern Time and lasted approximately 30 minutes. And during that time, the Dow Jones dropped about 9%, which is a huge drop. And the crash was triggered by a large sell order of these S&P 500 future contracts that were amplified by some algorithm. The details don't matter as much, but what happened was a huge decline in the stock market and no one knew why. And I remember seeing it happening. There was no apparent reason, but everybody was sure that someone knows something that
它始于美国东部时间下午2点32分钟，持续了大约30分钟。在那期间，道琼斯指数下跌了大约9%，这是一个巨大的跌幅。这次暴跌是由标普500指数期货合约的大额卖单引发的，并被某些算法放大了。细节其实并不那么重要，但发生的是股市的大幅下跌，而且没有人知道原因。我记得看到它发生。没有明显的原因，但每个人都确信有人知道某些
they didn't. So internet forums of stock investors were complete chaos, starting all sorts of rumors as stocks continue to fall. And I remember realizing the power of this financial panic, and I was panicking as well. And it was one of those short but pivotal moments, I think, that I realized that I didn't want my emotions to be tied to the state of the stock market. And soon after that, I applied to grad school and became a researcher of that phenomena. But I vividly remember that experience.
他们不知道的事情。因此，股票投资者的网络论坛一片混乱，随着股市继续下跌，各种谣言四起。我记得自己意识到了这种金融恐慌的力量，当时我也在恐慌。我认为，那是那些短暂但关键的时刻之一，我意识到我不想让自己的情绪与股市的状态绑定。不久之后，我申请了研究生院，并成为了该现象的研究员。但我对那段经历记忆犹新。
I mean, I'm thinking about the hours after the 9-11 attacks in the United States, you know, a couple decades ago. I remember working at a newspaper in Washington at the time, and, you know, the first few hours were so chaotic because it was not quite clear what was happening, who knew what, and there was a sense that things were unfolding that were larger than you and much more powerful than you that you didn't understand. And that produced incredible fear and incredible rumors about fresh horrors that were about to unfold.
我的意思是，我想到了美国发生“9·11”袭击之后的几个小时，你知道的，那已经是几十年前的事了。我记得当时在华盛顿的一家报纸工作，你知道的，最初的几个小时极其混乱，因为当时并不十分清楚发生了什么，谁知道什么，而且有一种感觉，事情正在以远超你、比你强大得多、你根本无法理解的方式展开。这产生了难以置信的恐惧，以及关于即将发生的新恐怖的种种惊人的谣言。
For sure. There's also a really interesting thing happened in September 11, which was after the first plane hit the towers, there was a huge anticipated affect. What is going to happen next? Is it going to be the end of it? And there's a lot of really interesting works showing that anticipated affect is actually stronger in intensity than the actual thing. And so people were not only kind of responding to what happened, but also extremely anxious
确实如此。9月11日还发生了一件非常有趣的事情，那就是在第一架飞机撞击双子塔之后，产生了一种巨大的预期影响。接下来会发生什么？这会是结束吗？有许多非常有趣的研究表明，预期影响在强度上实际上比实际事情本身还要强烈。因此，人们不仅是在对发生的事情做出反应，而且对即将发生的事情感到极度焦虑
of what is about to happen. I think that makes things so much stronger. I want to go a little bit further back in history. During World War II, Japan bombed Pearl Harbor. And shortly after that, fears about Japanese-Americans spread like wildfire across the United States. It's somewhat hard to imagine today, but thousands upon thousands of Japanese-American citizens
这让事情变得强烈得多。我想把历史再往前推一点。二战期间，日本轰炸了珍珠港。在那之后不久，对日裔美国人的恐惧像野火一样在美国各地蔓延。今天这有点难以想象，但成千上万的日裔美国公民
were rounded up and interned in camps. In some ways, this is at a much larger level, the same phenomenon that you saw at the stock market, that you saw at your protests in Jerusalem. The same idea magnified many times. Absolutely. You know, when groups feel panic and rage, they tend to, just like individuals, they tend to focus their attention sometimes on the wrong things and make decisions that sometimes are extremely destructive, that they would never have made these decisions without these emotions. And one of the things about collectives feeling these emotions is that it's not only that they feel these emotions, but they don't have any motivation to regulate them.
被抓起来并关押在集中营里。在某种程度上，这在更大的层面上，与你在股市中、在耶路撒冷的抗议活动中看到的现象是相同的。这是同一概念的许多倍放大。绝对是的。你知道，当群体感到恐慌和愤怒时，他们往往会像个人一样，有时把注意力集中在错误的事情上，做出有时极具破坏性的决定，如果没有这些情绪，他们绝不会做出这些决定。关于集体感受到这些情绪的一点是，不仅是他们感受到了这些情绪，而且他们没有任何动机去调节这些情绪。
In many cases when individuals feel negative emotions, they don't want to feel those emotions. So helping people regulate involves harnessing their basic motivation. But in these collective situations when groups feel emotions like rage or fear, they really want to feel those emotions because it feels good to express these emotions together. And so if you want to regulate them, you really need to find ways to bypass this motivational limitations. In the last few years, me and a lot of other people are trying to think about ways, creative ways, to overcome these motivational hurdles, to reduce collective anger, anxiety, and fear, and to increase hope in some of those very desperate situations because the outcomes can be so destructive that any form of regulation
在许多情况下，当个人感到负面情绪时，他们并不想感受到这些情绪。因此，帮助人们调节需要利用他们基本的动机。但在这些集体情况下，当群体感受到愤怒或恐惧等情绪时，他们真的很想感受到这些情绪，因为一起表达这些情绪感觉很好。所以如果你想调节它们，你真的需要找到绕过这些动机局限性的方法。在过去几年里，我和许多其他人一直在思考各种方法，创造性的方法，来克服这些动机障碍，以减少集体的愤怒、焦虑和恐惧，并在一些非常绝望的情况下增加希望，因为结果可能是如此具有破坏性，以至于任何形式的调节
may be a huge help. When I think about my emotions I usually think about the emotions that I am feeling. My happiness, my anger, my gratitude. Most of us don't think about emotions as collective experiences, but as Amit had seen on multiple occasions in his own life, emotions are in fact shared. They are experienced collectively. In time, he was to learn that when emotions are shared they can take on a life of their own and have surprising effects on us.
都可能是一个巨大的帮助。当我思考自己的情绪时，我通常会想到我正在感受的情绪。我的快乐、我的愤怒、我的感激。我们大多数人不会把情绪当作集体体验来看待，但正如阿米特在自己的生活中多次看到的那样，情绪实际上是共享的。它们是共同体验的。随着时间的推移，他逐渐认识到，当情绪被共享时，它们可以拥有属于自己的生命，并对我们产生令人惊讶的影响。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Amit Goldenberg is a psychologist at Harvard Business School. He studies what happens when the things we feel are shared by tens or millions of other people. He's found that shared emotions can have surprising effects on all of us. I mean, in October 1938, millions of Americans were listening to the radio
你正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。阿米特·戈尔登贝格是哈佛商学院的心理学家。他研究当我们的感受被千百万人共享时会发生什么。他发现，共享的情绪会对我们所有人产生惊人的影响。我的意思是，1938年10月，数百万美国人正在听收音机
when the broadcast was interrupted by what seemed like a news bulletin. I'm speaking from the roof of a broadcasting building. Announcers described an alien spaceship landing on a farm in New Jersey. Martian invaders soon emerged from the spaceship and started taking over the United States. I felt you hear a ringing to warn the people to evacuate the city as Martians approach Estimated in last two hours three million people have moved out along the roads to the north All communication with Jersey Shore closed ten minutes ago
这时广播被一场看似新闻快讯的内容打断了。我正在广播大楼的屋顶上发言。播音员描述了一艘外星飞船降落在新泽西州的一个农场上。火星入侵者很快从飞船中涌出，并开始接管美国。我仿佛听到警铃响起，警告人们在火星人逼近时疏散城市据估计，在过去两个小时里，已有三万人沿北部的道路撤离。与新泽西海岸的所有通信在十分钟前中断。
No more defenses Our army is wiped out. Artillery, Air Force, everything wiped out. This may be the last broadcast. So this was not an actual news bulletin, of course, but a fictional presentation called War of the Worlds created by the director Orson Welles. Can you remind us of the effect that this broadcast had on listeners, Amit? Yeah, so this created a widespread panic among listeners who basically thought that Martians took over the United States or the world. And, you know, panic thrives when there's ambiguity. No one has ever
没有更多的防御。我们的军队被全歼。炮兵、空军，一切都被全歼。这可能是最后的广播。所以这当然不是一个真正的新闻快讯，而是一个名为《世界大战》的虚构节目，由导演奥森·韦尔斯创作。阿米特，你能提醒我们一下这个广播对听众产生了什么影响吗？是的，这在听众中引发了广泛的恐慌，他们基本上以为火星人接管了美国或世界。而且，你知道，当存在模糊性时，恐慌就会滋生。从来没有人
experienced a Martian attack and no one even can imagine what is the right thing to do when Martians attack. Where do you go? There's no plane you can go or there's basically nothing to do. you can go or there's basically nothing to do. And so panic really kind of thrives in these situations. And this ambiguity just led to widespread panic. Yeah. So one of the things that we saw in the aftermath of the Orson Welles broadcast, but also in the aftermath of the Pearl Harbor bombings,
经历过火星人袭击，甚至没有人能想象火星人袭击时该做什么才是正确的。你要去哪里？没有飞机你可以去，或者基本上没有什么可做。你可以去，或者基本上没有什么可做。因此，恐慌在这些情况下真正滋生。而这种模糊性导致了广泛的恐慌。是的。因此，我们在奥森·韦尔斯广播之后看到的现象之一，在珍珠港轰炸事件之后，
in the aftermath of the stock market meltdown you saw in Israel, is that fear can spread very easily, almost like a highly infectious virus. Can you explain the idea of emotional contagion, Amit? Yeah. So generally speaking, emotion contagion involves the tendency of people to adopt the emotions of their social surrounding. Now, this is caused by a variety of mechanisms. We're wired to mimic our social environment, so there's a basic mechanism of mimicry. We use other people as information to evaluate our emotions, and so we take people's emotions as information
在你看到的以色列股市崩盘之后，恐惧可以非常容易地传播，几乎就像一种高度传染性的病毒。阿米特，你能解释一下情绪传染的概念吗？是的。所以总的来说，情绪传染涉及人们采纳其社会环境情绪的倾向。现在，这是由各种机制引起的。我们的天生机制就是模仿我们的社会环境，所以有一个基本的模仿机制。我们把其他人当作评估我们情绪的信息，因此我们将人们的情绪作为信息
for what we should feel. And there's also just natural activation of the brain, category activation of panic when you see a panic around you. Now there's something really interesting about emotion contagion, which is that we have an evolutionary tendency to attend specifically to negative emotions. So our ancestors were not able to doom scroll, so they didn't have an endless amount of negative emotional information.
关于我们应该有什么感受。当你看到周围有恐慌时，大脑也会自然激活，产生恐慌的类别激活。现在关于情绪传染有一个非常有趣的事情，那就是我们在进化上有一种趋势，即专门关注负面情绪。所以我们的祖先无法刷手机获取末日信息，所以他们没有源源不断的负面情感信息。
They observed reality as it unfolded, and negative situations were extremely informative to them. If there is an attack on one's village or if there's something that one needs to be afraid of, this is extremely informative. And so our general tendency to attend more to negativity leads to the fact that emotion contagion is usually much quicker and much stronger for negative emotions. So in 2012, the social media giant Facebook ran an experiment in emotional contagion. Many people were concerned about the ethics of this experiment, but what did Facebook
他们观察现实的展开，负面情况对他们来说信息量极大。如果有人对自己的村庄发动袭击，或者有什么需要害怕的事情，这信息量极大。因此，我们普遍更关注负面事物的倾向导致了这样一个事实：对于负面情绪而言，情绪传染通常要快得多、强烈得多。所以在2012年，社交媒体巨头脸书（Facebook）进行了一项关于情绪传染的实验。许多人对这个实验的伦理感到担忧，但脸书
do Amit? So, this is probably the most important paper that came during my PhD and it really impacted me for a variety of reasons. What basically, what Facebook did and they did the experiment in 2012 is basically for a period of a week, they took people who usually wrote a lot of posts on Facebook and for half of them, they reduced the posts that had negative emotions to almost minimum and for half of them, they reduced the posts that expressed positive emotions to almost minimum.
做了什么，阿米特？所以，这可能是我在读博士期间最重要的论文，它因各种原因真正影响了我。基本上，脸书所做的是——他们在2012年做了这个实验——在一周的时间里，他们挑选了那些通常在脸书上写很多帖子的人，对于其中一半人，他们将带有负面情绪的帖子减少到几乎为零；对于另一半人，他们将表达积极情绪的帖子减少到几乎为零。
And so, some of the participants basically saw just negative emotions on their feeds and some of the participants or the users saw saw just negative emotions on their feeds, and some of the participants or the users saw basically just positive emotions on their feeds. And then they looked what content do these participants or users produce. And they saw that it had an effect on the content that users were producing. So users who were exposed to more positive content tended to generate posts that were more positive.
因此，一些参与者基本上在他们的信息流中只看到负面情绪，而一些参与者或用户看到的内容基本上只有负面情绪，而一些参与者或用户看到的内容基本上只有积极情绪。然后他们观察这些参与者或用户产出了什么内容。他们发现这确实对用户产出的内容产生了影响。因此，接触更多积极内容的倾向于生成更积极的帖子。
And people who basically saw negative emotions on their feed mostly produced or produced more negative content by themselves. You told me that years earlier when you attended that protest or that series of protests in Jerusalem, you were very angry before you went out to the protest, but when you went there and you saw all these other people who were also angry, it made you even angrier. What do we know about how group processes modulate individual emotion? When we experience an emotion collectively, how does that change the emotion that we feel? Yeah, so the notion that when people get together, they become more emotional is one of the foundations of social sciences. So when I started to think about what makes groups
而那些基本上在信息流中看到负面情绪的人，大多自己产出了更多负面内容。你曾告诉我，多年前当你参加耶路撒冷的那场抗议或那一系列抗议时，你在去抗议之前非常生气，但当你去了那里，看到周围所有其他人也很生气时，这让你更加生气。关于群体过程如何调节个体情绪，我们知道了什么？当我们集体体验某种情绪时，这如何改变我们所感受到的情绪？是的，当人们聚在一起时，他们会变得更加情绪化这一观念是社会科学的基础之一。所以当我开始思考是什么让群体
emotional, one of the ideas I've had was that people may not be accurate in their evaluation of what other people feel. And if we think that other people are feeling stronger emotions than they actually are, we may conform to that emotional values, which leads the whole system to be amplified. Amit himself got to experience this crowd distortion effect some time ago. He had to give a series of high-stakes talks, as he was searching for a job as a professor. It was very stressful, but he felt he had gotten the hang of it by the time he got to the final talk. That was until he looked out into the audience.
情绪化时，我的想法之一是，人们在评估其他人感受时可能并不准确。如果我们认为其他人感受到的情绪比实际更强烈，我们可能会顺应这种情绪价值，从而导致整个系统被放大。阿米特本人不久前也经历了这种群体扭曲效应。当他在寻找教授职位时，他不得不做一系列高风险的演讲。这压力很大，但他觉得当他进行最后一次演讲时，他已经掌握了窍门。直到他向台下望去。
So when I was going into that talk, I thought to myself, oh, this is going to be just a breeze. You know, I've done this before and I feel very confident. But the moment I started my talk, I realized that there was a person in the audience was really not happy with what I had to say. I mean, I don't know this for sure. He may not have been happy because of something he had for breakfast. But I didn't care about that. I thought that he was angry at me.
所以当我走进那场演讲时，我心想，哦，这将会是一场轻而易举的事。你知道的，我以前做过这个，我感觉非常自信。但就在我开始演讲的那一刻，我意识到观众席里有一个人对我要说的话非常不高兴。我的意思是，我不能百分之百确定。他可能因为早饭吃得不顺心而不高兴。但我不在乎那个。我以为他在生我的气。
And I remember knowing that I should not be spending much of my time looking at him. And it is distracting and maybe not representative of what other people say, but I just could not get my eyes off of him. And I didn't get the job. And still, I didn't know if it was because of him or not because of him. But I remember that experience very, very vividly. One reason being in a crowd amplifies our emotions is that we preferentially pay attention
我记得我知道我不应该把大部分时间花在看他身上。这很让人分心，而且可能不代表其他人怎么看，但我的目光就是离不开他。我没有得到那份工作。尽管如此，我仍然不知道那是不是因为他。但我对那段经历记忆犹新。人群放大我们情绪的一个原因，是我们倾向于将注意力集中在人群中
to people in the crowd who are behaving emotionally. Amit ran an experiment that revealed how common this behavior is. We had people wear an eye tracker and we had them look at crowds with people expressing different emotional intensities. And what we could see was that people had a hard time dis-attaching their attention from the more emotional faces. It took them longer. They had to scan the crowd, but it took them longer. They spent longer time on those emotional faces.
那些表现出情绪化行为的人身上。阿米特做了一个实验，揭示了这种行为有多么普遍。我们让人们佩戴眼动仪，让他们观察人群，人群中人们表现出不同的情绪强度。我们能看到的是，人们很难将注意力从更情绪化的面孔上移开。这花了他们更长的时间。他们不得不扫描人群，但这花了他们更长的时间。他们在这些情绪面孔上花的时间更长。
And indeed their evaluations of the overall emotions were more intense than the actual emotion expressed by the crowd. You know, I'm thinking about those speeches that politicians give where they sometimes have their supporters sitting behind them as they're giving the speech. So you can see the politician in the front and the supporters in the back. And it's it's inevitable that you end up scanning the faces of all the people behind the politician.
事实上，他们对整体情绪的评估比人群实际表达的情绪更强烈。你知道的，我在想政客们发表的那些演讲，有时他们演讲时支持者坐在他们身后。所以你可以看到前面的政客和后面的支持者。不可避免地，你最终会扫描政客身后所有人的脸。
And it's true. Our eyes do gravitate to the person who seems the most expressive, the person who seems to have be experiencing the most emotions. Our eyes seem to be drawn to that person almost like a gravitational field. Absolutely. And I would say even further, much of the emotional content that we consume is collective in many ways. So when we scroll through our social media feeds, for example, and we try to understand what people feel about something, we don't just get one expression. We get multiple expressions, and then we try to understand what people feel about something. We don't just get one expression. We get multiple expressions, and then we need to aggregate these expressions and represent them in a sense. And so one of my students, Jonas Schone, extended our work of crowds to feeds.
确实如此。我们的眼睛确实会被那个看起来表情最丰富、似乎体验到最多情绪的人所吸引。我们的眼睛似乎被那个人吸引，几乎就像一个引力场。绝对是的。而且我还要进一步说，我们消费的大多数情感内容在很多方面都是集体的。例如，当我们滚动浏览社交媒体信息流，试图了解人们对某事的感受时，我们得到的不仅仅是一种表达。我们得到多种表达，然后我们试图了解人们对某事的感受。我们得到的不仅仅是一种表达。我们得到多种表达，然后我们需要聚合这些表达并在某种意义上代表它们。因此，我的学生之一乔纳斯·肖恩将我们对人群的研究扩展到了信息流。
And so what we show there is that people remember stronger emotions on their feeds much more. And this paints their perception of what the collective feels in response to certain events. So our representations of multiple emotions tend to be amplified, generally speaking. So you and your colleagues call this idea Acrophily. What is Acrophily, Amit? Yeah, so Acrophily is a takeoff on the term homophily.
我们在那里展示的是，人们对信息流中更强烈的情绪记忆得更深。这描绘了他们对群体为应对某些事件而产生的集体感受的感知。因此，总的来说，我们对多种情绪的表征往往会被放大。所以你和你的同事将这个概念称为“极端倾向性”。什么是极端倾向性，阿米特？是的，“极端倾向性”是借用了“同质倾向性”这个词。
So homophily is one of the most established phenomena in social sciences and it's basically attraction to people who are similar to you. Acro means extreme, and so acrophily means attraction to people who are more extreme than you. And the idea is that if you have two people who have the same distance from you or the same distance from you in terms of their views or their emotions, one is more extreme and one is less extreme, you would prefer to interact with the person who is more extreme than the person who is more extreme and one is less extreme. You would prefer to interact with
同质倾向性是社会科学中最确立的现象之一，它基本上是指被与你相似的人吸引。“Acro”意为极端，所以“极端倾向性”是指被比你更极端的人所吸引。这个想法是，如果你有两个人，他们在观点或情感上与你的距离相同，一个是极端的，一个是较不极端的，你会倾向于与更极端的人互动，而不是和一个更极端、一个较不极端的人互动。你会更倾向于与
the person who is more extreme than the person who is more moderate. And you can imagine if you play that out in your mind, if that attraction is even tiny, that leads the whole system to slowly polarize and become more and more emotional over time. And so we had a series of studies that examined that idea. What's interesting is that if you ask people, are you more attracted to people who are more extreme or less extreme, they often will say, no, no, I like moderates. I prefer moderates because they represent something
那个更极端的人互动，而不是那个较为温和的人。你可以想象，如果你在脑海中推演这个过程，如果这种吸引力哪怕只有一点点，也会导致整个系统慢慢极化，随着时间推移变得越来越情绪化和激动。所以我们做了一系列研究来检验这个想法。有趣的是，如果你问人们，你更容易被更极端的人吸引还是被不那么极端的人吸引？他们通常会说，不，不，我喜欢温和派。我更喜欢温和派，因为他们代表了
that I believe is better in some ways, or I believe is more balanced. But when you give them a choice, or when you have them to interact with someone who's less extreme or more extreme and you ask them, how much did you like that person? They tend to prefer the people who are more extreme. And that tendency, that acrophily, has a huge impact over time on the rate and the degree of segregation and polarization that may occur within a network. As we are drawn to notice individuals who show heightened emotion, we unconsciously
我认为在某些方面更好或更平衡的东西。但当你给他们选择，或者让他们与一个不太极端或更极端的人互动，并问他们：你有多喜欢那个人？他们往往会更喜欢那些更极端的人。这种倾向，即极端倾向性，随着时间的推移，对网络内部可能发生的隔离和极化的速率与程度产生了巨大的影响。当我们被吸引去注意到那些表现出情绪高涨的个人时，我们会在潜意识中
assume this heightened state of emotion is shared by the group as a whole. We ratchet up our own emotions to match our perception of the crowd. Besides the idea of emotion contagion, Amit has studied another aspect of collective emotion. He calls these emotional cascades. The best way to understand this is to start with an event that unfolded in 2014 in Ferguson, Missouri. So the event started at 12 p.m. where a police officer shot Mike Brown at his car. An hour later, Michael Brown's father posted a picture of himself holding a cardboard that says, the Ferguson police just executed my unarmed son. And you can already see tweets about Ferguson 2 PM, two hours after the incident, and rates
认为这种高涨的情绪是整个群体所共有的。我们拉高我们自己的情绪，以匹配我们对人群的感知。除了情绪传染的概念外，阿米特还研究了集体情绪的另一个方面。他称之为情感瀑布。理解这一点的最好方法是从2014年密苏里州弗格森发生的一起事件开始。事件始于中午12点，一名警官在车旁枪杀迈克·布朗。一小时后，迈克·布朗的父亲发了一张自己拿着纸板的照片，上面写着：“弗格森警察刚刚处决了我未武装的儿子。”你已经可以在下午2点看到关于弗格森的推文，也就是事件发生两小时后，并且频率
were increasing, reaching up to 30,000 tweets per hour by August 14, so five days later. I was a grad student at the time, and I was observing this as it unfolded, and I started to record all these tweets and kind of study them. And what I could see there really changed my perception about what makes collective emotions stronger. So one of the interesting things is that the emotions of individuals in the movement were calming down. So if a person wrote a second tweet about Ferguson, it would be less intense than the
在增加，到8月14日——也就是五天后——达到了每小时多达30,000条推文。我当时是个研究生，我目睹了这一切的展开，我开始记录所有这些推文并进行研究。我在那里看到的确实改变了我对是什么让集体情绪更强烈的看法。其中一个有趣的事情是，运动中个人的情绪正在平静下来。因此，如果一个人写了关于弗格森的第二条推文，它的强度会比
first. So people as individuals habituated to the story. But the whole system as a whole, at some point, started to increase in intensity. A great analogy for that is that of a forest fire. So if you look at a forest fire, sometimes if you look at the specific trees, you know, the trees they burn down and that's it, they're burnt. But the fire may increase in intensity over time as it accumulates more and more territory. And so if you want to think about the influence of forest fires, it's not enough to be thinking
第一条低。所以人们作为个体对这个故事习以为常了。但整个系统在某个时刻开始在强度上增加。一个很好的类比是森林大火。如果你看一场森林大火，有时如果你看特定的树，你知道，树被烧毁了，就这样，它们烧毁了。但随着大火积聚越来越多的领地，它的强度可能会随着时间的推移而增加。因此，如果你想思考森林大火的影响，光考虑
about the individual tree. You have to be taking a broader view and thinking of the collective phenomena here and how you take control of that. And so that's one insight of because emotions spread, they become more intense. A related idea is that collective emotions change what gets shared and expressed. So we've talked about the idea that more extreme emotions in some ways attract attention, but can you say a moment about the valence of that emotion? What happens when the emotion being expressed is positive versus negative? So one of the most basic findings in emotion research is what we call negativity bias,
单棵树是不够的。你必须采取更广泛的视角，考虑这里的集体现象以及如何控制它。这就是其中的一个洞察：因为情绪会传播，所以它们变得更强烈。一个相关的观点是，集体情绪改变了什么会被分享和表达。我们讨论过更极端的情绪在某种程度上会吸引注意力的观点，但你能谈谈这种情绪的效价吗？当表达的情绪是积极的与消极的时会发生什么？因此，情绪研究中最基本的发现之一就是我们所说的负面偏见，
which is people's tendency to attend more to negative emotions compared to positive emotions. And so one of the findings that we're starting to see when you look at what content people share on social media is that people generally tend to share more negative emotions compared to positive emotions. And this is interestingly especially true when these emotions are produced by people who are public figures. So for example, basically public figures and ordinary users, 20% of the tweets that they produce, for example, are negative. But if you look at shared content, content that's shared by public figures, 30% of it is negative. So there's a 10% increase of negativity shared by public figures. And that has a huge effect on the content that people consume on social media.
也就是人们倾向于比积极情绪更多地关注消极情绪。因此，当我们观察人们在社交媒体上分享什么内容时，开始看到的一个发现是，人们普遍倾向于分享更多消极情绪而不是积极情绪。有趣的是，当这些情绪由公众人物产生时，这一点尤其明显。例如，基本上公众人物和普通用户，他们产生的推文中，比如有20%是负面的。但如果你看被分享的内容，由公众人物分享的内容，其中30%是负面的。因此，公众人物分享的负面内容增加了10%。这极大地影响了人们在社交媒体上消费的内容。
So when you step back and look at this big picture, Amit, groups can amplify our emotions. They draw us to people with extreme views, and they especially draw us to negative emotions rather than positive emotions? That's right. So generally speaking, people tend to attend to emotions in general, and they tend to attend more to negative emotions. The fact that people tend to these negative emotions mean that they're more likely to share them, which means that their proportion in the content that people see increases. We also tend to amplify emotions by aggregating that emotional information. So in addition to this basic contagion effect, the fact that we over-represent in our attention and memory
所以当你退后一步看这个大局时，阿米特，群体可以放大我们的情绪。它们把我们吸引到持极端观点的人身边，尤其是把我们吸引到消极情绪而不是积极情绪身边？没错。因此，总的来说，人们倾向于关注一般的情绪，并且他们倾向于更多地关注负面情绪。人们倾向于关注这些负面情绪意味着他们更有可能分享它们，这意味着它们在人们看到的内容中的比例增加了。我们还通过聚合这些情绪信息来放大情绪。因此，除了这种基本传染效应之外，我们在注意力和记忆中过度表征
stronger emotional expressions, meaning that we tend to think that people's emotions are even stronger than they actually are. But even further, the fact that we prefer people who express more extreme emotions means that our social networks to begin with are more emotional. And so we have this cyclical loop of contagion, misperception, tie selection that contributes to that process of increased emotionality. And as we become sucked into that process, we essentially make the group itself larger, which in turn has the effect of sucking in even more people. That's right. That's exactly right. I'm wondering, Amit, if you've given thought to why our brains harness our individual emotions to the currents that run through groups.
更强烈的情感表达，这意味着我们倾向于认为人们的情感甚至比实际更强烈。不仅如此，我们更喜欢表达更极端情绪的人这一事实，意味着我们的社交网络从一开始就更加情绪化。因此，我们拥有了传染、错误感知、关系选择的循环回路，这促成了情绪化加剧的过程。随着我们被吸入那个过程中，我们实质上让群体本身变得更大，这反过来又会产生吸入更多人的效果。没错。完全正确。阿米特，我想知道你是否思考过为什么我们的大脑会将我们的个人情绪与贯穿群体的电流联系起来。
I mean, your data suggests that this does happen. I think we've all seen this firsthand, but why do you think it happens? Well, I would actually flip the order of importance here. I think that first and foremost, we're members of a collective system, and only after we're individuals. I think that as psychologists, we're kind of trained to think of people as individual entities. But really, everything that we know of individual brains is that we need social connections,
我的意思是，你的数据表明这种情况确实会发生。我想我们都亲眼见过这种情况，但你认为为什么会发生呢？嗯，实际上我想颠倒一下这里的重要性顺序。我认为首先也是最重要的，我们是一个集体系统的成员，其次才是个人。我认为作为心理学家，我们习惯于把人视为独立的实体。但实际上，关于个体大脑我们所了解的一切都表明，我们需要社会联系，
just like we need water or air. And our emotional experiences are not independent. They're mostly collective, and they're also experienced at the individual level. And so we have very few emotions that we feel as separate individuals. Many more emotions that we feel as part of family members, community members, national groups and collectives, sports fans, fan clubs, and so on and so forth. And so I would urge people who think about emotions to
就像我们需要水或空气一样。而且我们的情绪体验并不是独立的。它们大多是集体的，同时也是在个体层面体验到的。因此，我们作为独立个体会去感受的情绪其实非常少。我们感受到的更多情绪是作为家庭成员、社区成员、民族群体和集体、体育迷、粉丝俱乐部等的一员而体验到的。因此，我敦促那些思考情绪的人，
think of emotions and emotion regulation much more at the collective than the individual level. Shared emotions are neither good nor bad, but they can lead us to do things that are good for us or things that are bad for us. When we come back, how to step away from groups when they are leading us astray, and how to open the door to shared emotions we might never experience otherwise. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. Our emotions are designed to guide our behavior. When we are afraid, we feel like running or
更多地从集体层面而不是个体层面去思考情绪和情绪调节。共享的情绪无所谓好坏，但它们确实会引导我们去做对我们有利或有害的事情。稍后回来，我们将探讨当群体把我们引向歧途时如何抽身，以及如何打开通往从未体验过的共享情绪的大门。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们的情绪旨在指导我们的行为。当我们害怕时，我们会想要奔跑或
hiding. Sadness tells us that something is wrong, and to avoid doing things in the future that put us in the same position. Joy and delight and awe prompt us to do more of the things that bring us joy and delight and awe. As a deeply social species, it is unsurprising that we are also influenced powerfully, not just by our own emotions, but the emotions coursing through the people around us. It makes sense that fear in others should spread contagiously to us, that we get swept up in collective feelings of anger, envy, and triumph. Amit Goldenberg is a psychologist at Harvard Business School. He is fascinated by the effect of group-level emotions.
躲藏。悲伤告诉我们出了问题，并让我们在未来避免做让自己陷入同样境地的事情。喜悦、快乐和敬畏促使我们去更多地做那些能给我们带来喜悦、快乐和敬畏的事情。作为一个高度社会化的物种，我们不仅受到自身情绪的强烈影响，还受到周围人群情绪的强烈影响，这并不令人意外。其他人身上的恐惧会像传染病一样蔓延到我们身上，我们被愤怒、嫉妒和胜利的集体情绪所席卷，这是合乎逻辑的。阿米特·戈尔登贝格是哈佛商学院的心理学家。他深深着迷于群体层面情绪的影响。
Amit, when your son was small, he once fell off his high chair. What caused this to happen? What happened? And what did it teach you about the ways in which we think about shared emotions? Well, first of all, I'm afraid it was failure in parenting that caused that to happen. We had a new high chair that we've never used. And when my wife, Jenna, put our son, Levy, who's just a baby, to eat, a few moments later he kind of leaned forward and fell off the high chair and landed on his face. Oh my God.
阿米特，当你的儿子还小的时候，他有一次从高脚椅上摔了下来。是什么导致了这件事的发生？发生了什么？这让你对我们看待共享情绪的方式有了什么认识？嗯，首先，恐怕那是育儿上的失误才导致了这件事的发生。我们有一个从未使用过的新高脚椅。当时我妻子珍娜把我们还是婴儿的儿子列维抱上去吃饭，过了一会儿，他有点向前倾身，然后从高脚椅上摔了下来，脸朝下着地了。哦，天哪。
And that was a huge moment of panic. Obviously everybody were panicking. Levi was panicking because he was just hit in the face. Jenna was panicking and feeling a lot of guilt because she forgot to buckle the seat in the proper way. And I was also panicking because, you know, this is one of those moments where you say, oh my God, this is exactly what you're afraid of as a parent. I was standing at the side and I saw Levi panicking and Jenna's panicking. And I was also internally panicking, but I felt that the appropriate response was to not express my panic and to in some ways offset the panic that Jenna felt to maybe help Levy calm down and realize that we have things under control. And I think that parents do this all the time. We see what our partner is expressing and we ask, is this the appropriate response? Sometimes
那是一个极度恐慌的时刻。显然每个人都在恐慌。列维在恐慌，因为他刚刚脸部着地。珍娜在恐慌，并且感到非常内疚，因为她忘记了以正确的方式扣好安全带。我也在恐慌，因为你知道，这是那种你会说“哦，天哪，这正是你作为一个父母所害怕的事情”的时刻。我站在一旁，看到列维在恐慌，珍娜也在恐慌。我的内心也在恐慌，但我觉得合适的反应是不表达我的恐慌，并且在某种程度上抵消珍娜感受到的恐慌，以帮助列维平静下来，并意识到一切都在我们的掌控之中。我想父母们一直在这样做。我们看到伴侣在表达什么，然后会问：这是合适的反应吗？有时候
we overreact, sometimes we underreact, and if we're good partners, we offset our partner's responses. So I see each member of a collective as trying to steer the group in the appropriate way by modifying their own emotions. And so the best way to see it is in family units, which are small, and each person has a huge impact on the unit. And so in this unit, parents and people are expressing their emotions to try to get the group to feel in the appropriate way. So you've done research that looks at how when two people are in a relationship, they
我们反应过度，有时我们反应不足，如果我们是好伴侣，我们会去平衡伴侣的反应。因此，我认为集体中的每个成员都在试图通过修改自己的情绪来以合适的方式引导团队。所以，最好的观察方式是在小型的家庭单位中，每个人对这个单位都有巨大的影响。在这个单位中，父母和每个人都在表达他们的情绪，试图让团队感受到合适的情绪。所以你做过研究，研究当两个人处于恋爱关系中时，他们
often cue off each other such that the emotional unit now stays in balance. Tell me a little bit about this work on what you call emotional compensation. Yeah. So what we do in these experiments is we give parents a scenario. So for example, you have two boys and a girl, Mark, David, and Jenny. Twelve-year-old Jenny is the oldest. Last week, your partner smelled alcohol on Jenny's breath when she came home. Your partner was very surprised and asked Jenny, were you drinking alcohol? Jenny immediately replies, yes, I drink with my friends. So what? Already as a parent, you're starting to get angry. Yesterday,
如何经常顺应彼此的信号，从而使情绪单位保持平衡。跟我讲讲这项关于你所谓的“情绪补偿”的研究吧。好的。我们在这些实验中所做的是给父母提供一个场景。比如，你有两个男孩和一个女孩，马克、大卫和珍妮。12岁的珍妮是老大。上周，你伴侣在珍妮回家时闻到了她身上的酒气。你的伴侣非常惊讶，问珍妮：“你喝酒了吗？”珍妮立刻回答：“对啊，我和朋友喝了。那又怎样？”作为父母，你已经开始生气了。昨天，
your friend called and told you that she ran into Jenny on the street and Jenny seemed quite drunk. You and your partner sit to talk with Jenny. And so in this scenario, the parents hear the other parents saying, this is a huge deal, your partner says to Jenny, extremely angry. I know kids who are drinking alcohol at this age, drinking destroyed their lives for good and it will destroy your life too. So it turns out that when they hear their partner being overly angry, they actually lower down the anger to try to create some balance response. And what we find, and that's the most interesting thing, is that parents who tend to compensate for their partner over or under reactions, generally tend to report happier marriage, which is not what you would expect this thing. You would expect that parents who are congruent in their responses are happier. But in fact,
你的朋友打电话告诉你，她在街上遇到了珍妮，珍妮看起来喝得挺醉。你和你的伴侣坐下来和珍妮谈话。在这个场景中，父母听到另一个父母说：“这事太严重了，”你的伴侣对珍妮说，极其愤怒，“我认识这个年纪喝酒的孩子，喝酒彻底毁了他们的人生，也会毁了你的人生。”事实证明，当他们听到伴侣表现得过度愤怒时，他们实际上会降低自己的愤怒，以试图创造某种平衡的反应。而我们发现的最有趣的事情是，那些倾向于补偿伴侣过度反应或反应不足的父母，通常会报告更幸福的婚姻，这并不是你对这种情况的预期。你可能会期望那些在反应上高度一致的父母更幸福。但事实上，
collective systems need balance and if a system has the tools to balance itself, that is a predictor of a more successful unit. unit. Amit says skilled leaders can help regulate the collective emotions of entire nations. When Franklin Delano Roosevelt told Americans suffering through the Great Depression that they had nothing to fear but fear itself, he was trying to calm the panic that was engulfing many households.
集体系统需要平衡，如果一个系统拥有自我平衡的工具，这就是一个更成功的团队的预测指标。阿米特说，熟练的领导者可以帮助调节整个国家的人民的集体情绪。当富兰克林·德拉诺·罗斯福告诉正在经历大萧条的美国人民，他们除了恐惧本身之外没有什么好害怕的时，他正试图平息席卷许多家庭的恐慌情绪。
he was trying to calm the panic that was engulfing many households. Corporate leaders, such as Steve Barmer at Microsoft, have shown how you can modulate emotion in the other direction. In this speech, for example, to rev up software developers. Developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers,
他正试图平息席卷许多家庭的恐慌情绪。微软的史蒂夫·鲍尔默等企业领导者展示了如何向另一个方向调节情绪。例如，在这次演讲中，为了调动软件开发人员的积极性。开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，
developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers,
开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，
developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers, developers,. It insts a lot of passion. When we think about leaders and emotion regulation, we often think about how can leaders reduce negative emotions. But leaders play a really important role in increasing positive emotions within their groups and organizations. It starts with joy, happiness, and in this case, it's passion. Balmer's passion is so strong that it's contagious. He doesn't need to fake it. It comes naturally to him. He sweats during this speech, and it's just a great gift that someone has as a leader. Rituals are also a way people can regulate collective emotions. Amit says you see rituals
开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员，开发人员。这注入了极大的热情。当我们考虑领导者和情绪调节时，我们通常会考虑领导者如何减少消极情绪。但领导者在增加其团队和组织内的积极情绪方面发挥着非常重要的作用。它始于快乐、幸福，而在这种情况下，就是热情。鲍尔默的热情如此强烈，以至于具有感染力。他不需要假装。这对他来说是自然而然的。他在演讲时流汗，这正是作为一个领导者所拥有的伟大天赋。仪式也是人们调节集体情绪的一种方式。阿米特说你可以看到各种仪式
in religious settings, at cultural events and on sports fields. So there's all sorts of ceremonies, start from physical touch. So a player is standing on the penalty line and they're fist bumping everyone in their team. Why is that? I mean, why do high intensity law firms get together and drink on Friday afternoons? They do this as a ritual to help resolve the anxiety that was building up during the week and get these people ready to spend some time with their family when they're not
存在于宗教场所、文化活动和运动场上。所以有各种各样的仪式，从身体接触开始。例如，一个球员站在罚球线上，与他们团队中的每个人碰拳。这是为什么呢？我的意思是，为什么高强度的律所会在周五下午聚在一起喝酒？他们这样做是为了作为一种仪式，帮助缓解一周中积聚的焦虑，让这些人准备好花时间陪家人，而不会
apt up from a really busy week of work. Yeah, or if you think about morning rituals, for example, probably the same idea. Absolutely. We talked about the fact that feeling negative emotions together feels better, but it also helps us to understand that people are feeling negative emotions with us as a form both to amplify these negative emotions in a in a concise way but also to control them. The rituals control variability and we use rituals to have a specific emotional experience in a controlled way. Another way of nudging a group's emotions in a particular direction involves teaching people that their opponents are capable of change. Amit, you've tested an intervention like this with a
被真正忙碌的工作周搞得精神紧绷。是的，或者如果你想想早晨的仪式，比如，可能也是同样的理念。绝对是的。我们讨论过这样一个事实：一起感受消极情绪感觉更好，但它也帮助我们理解，人们与我们一起感受消极情绪，既是一种以简明的方式放大这些消极情绪的形式，也是为了控制它们。仪式控制了变异性，我们利用仪式以一种受控的方式获得特定的情绪体验。引导群体的集体情绪朝特定方向发展的另一种方法是，教导人们他们的对手是有能力改变的。阿米特，你曾对一个
group of both Jewish and Palestinian students. Can you describe the intervention and tell me what happened? Yeah, we're in the era of hatred, and hatred should be very clearly differentiated from anger. When you feel angry, you want to make things right, and you want to fix things. When you feel hatred, the person on the other side, you already established the idea that the person on the other side cannot be changed, and there's nothing that can be done. But you can't tell Israelis Palestinians can change because, and you can't tell Palestinians that Israelis can change because they've been educated all their life that the other side hates them. And so you have to do it in an indirect way. So we developed these leadership workshops where we talked about identifying change
由犹太和巴勒斯坦学生组成的群体测试过这样一种干预措施。你能描述一下这个干预措施并告诉发生了什么吗？好的，我们处于一个充满仇恨的时代，仇恨应该与愤怒明确区分开来。当你感到愤怒时，你想把事情纠正，你想解决问题。当你感到仇恨时，对于另一方的人，你已经确立了这样一种观念：对方是不可能改变的，而且无济于事。但你不能直接告诉以色列人巴勒斯坦人是可以改变的，你也无法告诉巴勒斯坦人以色列人是可以改变的，因为他们一生受到的教育都是对方仇恨自己。所以你必须以一种间接的方式来做这件事。因此，我们开发了这些领导力工作坊，我们在其中讨论如何将改变
in general as a leader and thinking about groups as as malleable entities. This is based on Carol Dweck's idea of malleability and we show that even when you teach when you teach people about group malleability, and we show that even when you teach people about group malleability, even when you don't tell them that they need to apply this to the specific context of the conflict, the idea of malleability seeps into a lot of their aspects of their thinking and changes how they feel and how they think about resolving the conflict. Amit Goldenberg is a psychologist at Harvard Business School. Amit, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
作为领导者的一般特征来识别，并将群体视为具有可塑性的实体。这基于卡罗尔·德韦克的“可塑性”理念，我们表明，即使你教导人们关于群体的可塑性，即使你不告诉他们需要将这一点应用到冲突的具体情境中，可塑性的理念也会渗透到他们许多方面的思考中，并改变他们的感受以及他们对如何解决冲突的看法。阿米特·戈尔登贝格是哈佛商学院的心理学家。阿米特，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。
Thank you. There are situations where we all get to see collective emotions in action. It doesn't matter if you live in a bustling city or a tiny village. It makes no difference if you're a member of a vast intergenerational household or living on your own. You might be religious or you might be a devout atheist. Humans around the world invoke supernatural forces when it looks like their sports teams might lose. They take part in annual festivals that demand time, effort, and money.
谢谢。在某些情况下，我们所有人都能看到集体情绪在起作用。无论你住在繁华的城市还是偏远的小村庄，都没有区别。无论你是庞大的多代同堂家庭的一员还是独自生活，都没有区别。你可能是有信仰的人，也可能是坚定的无神论者。当他们的运动队看起来要输掉比赛时，世界各地的人们都会呼吁超自然力量。他们参加需要时间、精力和金钱的年度节日。
They mark important moments, such as marriages, births, and deaths, with intricately choreographed scripts. These festivals, rites, and scripts are largely designed to shape the emotions we feel collectively. The psychology of rituals perfectly complements the story we heard today from Amit Goldenberg. Some time ago, I interviewed the anthropologist Dimitris Zigalatas. He told me not only about his research, but about the time he himself was induced to take part in one of the most fearsome rituals in the world. He was terrified, yes, but he said,
他们用精心编排的脚本来标记重要的时刻，例如婚礼、出生和葬礼。这些节日、仪式和脚本在很大程度上旨在塑造我们共同感受到的情绪。仪式的心理学完美地补充了我们今天从阿米特·戈尔登贝格那里听到的故事。不久前，我采访了人类学家迪米特里斯·齐加拉塔斯。他不仅告诉我他的研究，还讲了他自己如何被诱导参与世界上最可怕的仪式之一的经历。是的，他当时吓坏了，但他说，
What I also felt was this jolt of exhilaration that lasted not just for a few minutes, not just for a few hours, but in fact for several days. When we come back, a bonus Emotions 2.0 feature into the deep history and powerful psychology of Connecticut. His research has taken him across the planet. In his travels, Demetrius has found common cultural practices among people living in far-flung places. Many of these practices involve dangerous, difficult, or expensive rituals. The
我同时感到的还有一种兴奋感，这种兴奋感不仅持续了几分钟，不仅持续了几个小时，实际上持续了好几天。稍后回来，我们将带来一个关于康涅狄格州深厚历史和强大心理学的“情绪 2.0”特辑。他的研究带他走遍了全球。在旅行中，迪米特里斯发现在偏远地区生活的人们之间存在着共同的文化习俗。其中许多习俗涉及危险、困难或昂贵的仪式。这些
rituals themselves are often dramatic. They are also regularly incomprehensible to outsiders. But when you peer beneath the surface, rituals actually reveal a great deal about the human mind and the psychological features that people around the world have in common. Dimitris Zygalatas, welcome to Hidden Brain. Hi, Shankar. Thank you for inviting me. Dimitris, some years ago, you found yourself in the Spanish village of San Pedro, Manrique,
仪式本身通常充满戏剧性。它们对外人来说也常常是不可理解的。但当你透过表面窥探时，仪式实际上揭示了许多关于人类心灵以及世界各地人们所共有的心理特征的信息。迪米特里斯·齐加拉塔斯，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。你好，尚卡尔。谢谢你邀请我。迪米特里斯，几年前，你发现自己身处西班牙的圣佩德罗-曼里克村，
and you met a man named Alejandro. How did you first come into contact with him? So, I was doing research on fire-walking rituals in Greece. That was for my doctoral research. And after that, I found out that there's another place in Europe where fire-walking rituals are performed. And this is the small village called San Pedro Manrique. So I just showed up there.
你遇到了一个叫亚历杭德罗的人。你是怎么第一次跟他取得联系的？当时我正在希腊研究走火仪式。那是我的博士研究。在那之后，我发现欧洲还有另一个地方会举行走火仪式。这就是那个叫圣佩德罗-曼里克的村庄。所以我当时就直接去了那里。
I started asking people if they knew about this ritual. And as it turns out, it was a really big deal in that community. So one of the first people who others pointed me to was Alejandro. People hold him in very high esteem in that village because he's one of the oldest fire walkers. And he in fact has been doing this ritual for many decades. So I understand that he was in his 70s when you were talking with him. Can you paint me a detailed picture of the fire walking ritual as it was practiced in this small Spanish village? We are talking about a village of 600 inhabitants that is in the middle of pretty much nowhere. And yet, people have built this large open amphitheater that can host 3,000 spectators.
我开始问人们是否知道这个仪式。事实证明，这在当地是个了不起的大事。其他人向我推荐的第一批人里就有亚历杭德罗（Alejandro）。他在那个村子里的声望非常高，因为他是年纪最大的火中行走者之一。事实上，他进行这个仪式已经有几十年了。据我所知，你和他交谈时他已经七十多岁了。你能否向我详细描绘一下这个西班牙小村庄里实行的火中行走仪式？我们说的是一个只有600名居民的村庄，几乎地处偏远。然而，人们却建造了一个能容纳3000名观众的大型露天圆形剧场。
Wow. And they only use it once a year for the purposes of this ritual. So clearly this is very important to them. On the summer solstice, every June, people start gathering in the central square. They engage in all kinds of processions and other celebrations throughout the day. And in the evening, they all join hands and they form this human chain. And they start marching up the hill in lockstep towards that venue. And once everybody takes their place,
哇。而且他们一年只为了这个仪式的目的使用一次。显然这对他门非常重要。在每年六月的夏至那天，人们开始聚集在中央广场。他们在整整一天里参与各种游行和其他庆典。到了晚上，大家手拉手形成一条人链。他们迈着整齐的步伐开始向山上的那个场地进发。当所有人都各就各位后，
at exactly midnight, people start taking off their shoes and they face a large pit of coals. This has been produced by two tons of oak wood that has been burning for hours. And it forms this bed of glowing coals. We actually measured the temperatures there at 1200 Fahrenheit. That's enough to melt aluminum.
在午夜整点，人们开始脱掉鞋子，面对着一个巨大的煤坑。这是由两吨燃烧了数小时的橡木产生的。它形成了一层发光的煤床。我们在那里实际测量过温度，达到了华氏1200度。这足以熔化铝。
My gosh. And while faced with this bed of coals, they take somebody on their back and they walk barefoot across it on the burning fire. Wow, and this was true of Alejandro as well. He would carry someone across this bed of fire? Correct. In fact, one time I saw him carrying his niece, who was significantly larger than him. Alejandro is a tiny man.
天哪。当面对这层煤床时，他们把一个人背在背上，光着脚走过燃烧的火堆。哇，亚历杭德罗也是如此吗？他会背着人走过这片火海吗？没错。事实上，有一次我看到他背着他的侄女，她比他重得多。亚历杭德罗是个瘦小的人。
So he struggled to balance her on his soldiers. People offered to help him, but then he just waved his hand and he went through and did it. You once asked Alejandro if he would ever stop engaging in this ritual. I want to play you a clip of what he said in Spanish. Can you translate what he told you, Dimitris? I don't have to climb up to the top of the tower to get through it. He said, what do you mean? He said, well, I cannot go there because if I do that, if I saw it without being able to do it, I would climb on the bell tower and jump off and kill myself. So the following year, Alejandro got some news from his doctor. What was it, Dimitris?
所以他很难把她平衡在自己的肩膀上。人们提出要帮他，但他只是挥了挥手，然后就走过去完成了。你曾经问过亚历杭德罗是否会停止参与这个仪式。我想放一段他在西班牙语中所说的话的片段。你能翻译一下他跟你说了什么吗，迪米特里斯（Dimitris）？我不需要爬到塔顶去完成它。他说，你是什么意思？他说，嗯，我不能去那里，因为如果我那样做，如果我看着它却无法做到，我就会爬上钟楼跳下去自杀。所以在第二年，亚历杭德罗得到了医生的一些消息。是什么消息，迪米特里斯？
I heard from Alejandro's son, Mamel, that his doctor told him he had detected some arrhythmia in his heart and therefore he banned him from doing the ritual. But things took a dramatic turn that night. I was in the central square with his son preparing for the procession that would lead us to the venue and at some point Mamel pulled me out of the chain. I said, what's happening? Mamel says, come with me and you'll see. So he took me to his father's house
我从亚历杭德罗的儿子马梅尔（Mamel）那里听说，他的医生告诉他，检测到了他心脏有一些心律失常，因此禁止他参加这个仪式。但那天晚上事情发生了戏剧性的转变。我和他的儿子在中央广场准备将引导我们前往会场的游行，不知在什么时候，马梅尔把我和人链拉开了。我说，怎么了？马梅尔说，跟我来，你就知道了。于是他带我去了他父亲的家里
and he announced, he said, Dad, I know you cannot do the ritual, so I'm going to carry you through the fire. And Alejandro just looked at him for a few seconds, he hugged him, and then they cried together. looked at him for a few seconds, he hugged him, and then they cried together. So we left the house and we walked towards the venue. And indeed, Mamel was one of the first persons to walk across the fire. He took off his shoes, he took his father on his back, and he crossed the burning coals. At that point, the crowd was ecstatic.
并宣布道，爸，我知道你不能参加这个仪式了，所以我要背着你穿过火海。亚历杭德罗看着他几秒钟，拥抱了他，然后他们一起哭了。看着他几秒钟，拥抱了他，然后他们一起哭了。于是我们离开房子，向会场走去。确实，马梅尔是第一批走过火海的人之一。他脱下鞋子，把父亲背在背上，走过了燃烧的煤炭。那一刻，人群欣喜若狂。
Everybody was cheering, his family rushed to hike him. But then suddenly, Alejandro turned towards them and with a sharp gesture, he told them to stop. Everybody went completely silent, 3,000 people. You could hear a pin drop as Alejandro turned around, facing the fire. And he just went ahead and crossed it again by himself this time.
每个人都在欢呼，他的家人冲过去抱住他。但突然之间，亚历杭德罗转向他们，用一个严厉的手势示意他们停下。全场顿时一片寂静，整整3000人。当亚历杭德罗转过身面对火堆时，连针掉在地上的声音都听得见。然后他一个人再次走过去，这一次是他自己一个人。
You can't go around. You can't go around. You can't go around. Yeah. Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, Alejandro about his choice to endanger his heart against his doctor's advice. What did he tell you afterwards, Dimitris? It was actually not the first time I've heard this from a firewalker. He said something like, my doctor said that if I do the firework, something terrible might happen to my heart.
你不能绕过去。你不能绕过去。你不能绕过去。是啊。嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，亚历杭德罗关于他不听医生劝告而拿心脏冒险的选择。他事后对你说了什么，迪米特里斯？这其实不是我第一次从火中行走者那里听到这种话。他大致是这么说的，我的医生说，如果我进行火中行走，我的心脏可能会发生可怕的事情。
But does he know what will happen to my heart if I don't do the firework? You know, it seems almost that there is a theme that shows up again and again in your research into rituals. When you look at them from the outside, they can seem incomprehensible, bewildering, but seen from the inside, the people who practice these rituals really cherish them, even when they carry significant costs. And in some ways, that's what you were hearing from Alejandro, wasn't it? Absolutely. Yes, across all kinds of different contexts, they carry so much meaning that people consider them to be a fundamental part of who they are as individuals and an equally fundamental part of their collective identity, who they are as group members. So we've looked at one example of a ritual that carried enormous physical
但他知道如果我不进行火中行走，我的心脏会发生什么吗？你知道，在你的仪式研究中，似乎总有一种主题一再出现。当你从外部看它们时，它们可能显得不可思议、令人困惑，但从内部来看，那些践行这些仪式的人确实非常珍惜它们，即使它们要付出巨大的代价。在某种程度上，这就是你从亚历杭德罗那里听到的，不是吗？完全正确。是的，在各种不同的语境下，它们承载了如此多的意义，以至于人们认为它们是作为个体的核心部分，同样也是集体身份的核心部分，即他们作为群体成员的身份。所以我们看了一个付出巨大身体
risks, but of course rituals also carry other forms of risks and other costs. Tell us what pilgrims endured during the Kummela festival in India. The Kummela is one of the most important Hindu pilgrimages in the world. And this is arguably the biggest congregation of human beings in known history. Last time somebody counted there were about 150 million people attending the festivities. It takes place every 12 years and it happens on the banks of four sacred rivers, the Ganges being one of them and people might take several weeks to travel there from all parts of India and
风险的仪式例子，但当然仪式也带有其他形式的风险和其他代价。请告诉我们朝圣者在印度的库姆大节（Kummela）期间忍受了什么。库姆大节是世界上最重要的印度教朝圣活动之一。这可以说是已知历史中规模最大的人类集会。上一次有人统计时，大约有1.5亿人参加了庆祝活动。它每12年举行一次，发生在四条圣河的河岸上，恒河就是其中之一，人们可能需要花几个星期的时间从印度的各个地方前往那里
beyond and when they reach it, the festival lasts for a month. Some people actually stay for the entire month. And during that month, you can imagine, it's such an incredibly crowded place. People live in tents. They bathe in the river. They drink from the river. And the Ganges is possibly the most polluted river on earth. So there's definitely a high risk of infectious diseases spreading. It's very hot during the day, but it's freezing cold during the night. So this ritual is full of hearts.
以及其他地方，当他们到达时，节日持续一个月。实际上有些人会待满整整一个月。正如你所想象的，在那一个月里，这是一个极其拥挤的地方。人们住在帐篷里。他们在河里洗澡。他们喝河里的水。恒河可能是地球上污染最严重的河流。因此，传染病传播的高风险绝对是存在的。白天非常热，但晚上却冷得结冰。所以这个仪式充满了困难。
I mean, at a more prosaic level, you've also studied rituals that are just financially costly, and many rituals fall under this category. certainly staying in a place like India. There are many families in India who celebrate weddings by going into extreme debt. Can you talk about that, Dimitris? This is something that is actually very similar
我的意思是，在更平庸的层面上，你也研究过纯粹在财务上付出高昂代价的仪式，许多仪式都属于这一类。当然，在印度这样一个地方待着。印度有许多家庭通过背负极端债务来庆祝婚礼。你能谈谈这个吗，迪米特里斯？这其实非常相似
to what I've seen in my home country. I come from Greece, so in rural areas of Greece, certainly when I was younger, when I was a kid, I've seen many instances of people going into debt to finance their children's wedding. In India, there's this local NGO which estimated over 60% of all Indian households, they turn to moneylenders in order to finance their children's weddings. And of course, they have to pay extortionate rates.
与我在祖国看到的情况。我来自希腊，所以在希腊的农村地区，当然在我年轻的时候，当我还是个孩子的时候，我见过许多人为了资助孩子的婚礼而负债累累的例子。在印度，有一个当地的非政府组织估计，超过60%的印度家庭为了资助孩子的婚礼而转向高利贷者。当然，他们必须支付高得离谱的利息。
And in many cases, they will sign contracts that get them into voluntary servitude over a period of years, so intensive labor, to be able to pay those debts off. So hearing about these ordeals, people on the outside might wonder, why would anyone voluntarily go through such hardship? And one thing you've done is actually ask participants that very question.
在许多情况下，他们会签署合同，让自己在一段时间内陷入非自愿的奴役状态，也就是高强度的劳动，以便能够还清这些债务。因此，听到这些磨难，外人可能会想，为什么会有人自愿经历这样的艰辛？而你做过的一件事就是直接问参与者这个问题。
And you've discovered a paradox when you ask someone like Alejandro or a pilgrim in the Kumbh Mela, why they do what they do. What do they tell you, Dimitris? I have asked hundreds, if not thousands of people this question, why do you do your rituals in general? Or why do you do this particular ritual? And one of the most astonishing things that never ceases to amaze me is that even in the case of rituals that involve
当你问像亚历杭德罗或库姆大节的朝圣者他们为什么要这样做时，你发现了一个悖论。他们对你说了什么，迪米特里斯？我问过几百甚至几千人这个问题，你们为什么总的来说要进行仪式？或者你们为什么要做这个特定的仪式？最令人惊讶的事情之一，也是永远让我惊叹不已的是，即使是在那些涉及
extraordinary material costs, physical effort, physical risks, most people would just look at me and say, what do you mean why we do our rituals? This is just what we do. This is who we are. You call this the ritual paradox. Unpack that idea for me. So the paradox is that on the one hand, people attribute tremendous meaning and importance to those rituals. Sometimes they will tell me this is the most important event of their lives and yet when I ask them why they do it they very often cannot come up with an answer. So you had first-hand experience of what it was like to participate in one of these
巨大的物质成本、体力付出、身体风险的仪式中，大多数人也只是看着我并说，你是什么意思，我们为什么要做仪式？这就是我们所做的。这就是我们是谁。你称之为仪式悖论。为我解开这个概念吧。所以这个悖论在于，一方面，人们将巨大的意义和重要性归于这些仪式。有时他们会告诉我这是他们一生中最重大的事件，然而当我问他们为什么要这么做时，他们往往给不出答案。
rituals when you were a small boy growing up in Greece. I understand when you were eight years old, your dad took you on an important, let's call it an expedition. Can you describe where he took you and what you saw? So this was a football stadium. And by football, I mean what the United States people call soccer, which in many parts of the world, my home country included, can be an almost religious-like activity. People have very strong loyalties towards their team. So at eight years old, I went into a stadium packed with 45,000 people, and I noticed that as soon as the game started, everybody jumped up and never sat down again. And what followed from that moment on was one of the most unbelievable experiences of
当你还是个在希腊长大的小男孩时，你曾亲身体验过参与其中一个仪式的感受。据我所知，当你八岁的时候，你父亲带你去了一次重要的，我们称之为远征的活动。你能描述一下他带你去了哪里以及你看到了什么吗？所以这是一个足球场。我说的足球，是指美国人所说的英式足球（soccer），在世界的许多地方，包括我的祖国，这可以是一项几乎具有宗教性质的活动。人们对自己的球队有着非常强烈的忠诚度。所以在我八岁的时候，我走进了一个挤满45,000人的体育场，我注意到比赛一开始，每个人都跳了起来，就再也没有坐下。从那一刻开始，接下来的事情是我
my younger life. People lit thousands of flares and torches and fireworks and the entire stadium turned into this ball of fire. It really looked like a volcano. People chanting in synchrony, jumping up and down in synchrony, lighting those flares, which of course meant that as soon as the game started, it had to be paused for several minutes just for the air to clear. And my father kept picking me up so that I could watch the game, but I didn't even care
我童年最不可思议的经历之一。人们点燃了数千支信号弹、火炬和烟花，整个体育场变成了一个火球。它看起来真像一座火山。人们齐声歌唱，齐声上下跳跃，点燃那些信号弹，这当然意味着比赛一开始，就必须暂停几分钟，好让空气恢复清晰。我父亲一直把我抱起来，这样我就可以看比赛，但我甚至不在乎
about the game. All I cared about were all of those incredible collective rituals that were happening around me. So as I was hearing the story, Dimitris, I was sort of seeing the eight-year-old version of you essentially becoming, you know, an anthropologist before our eyes, sort of observing all the people around you and asking why they were doing what they were doing But it's also the case that you became a fan of the sport but also of this particular team See most people they they don't show up at the temple when they're eight years old just because they had an internal yearning to worship
比赛。我在乎的全都是发生在我周围的那些不可思议的集体仪式。当我听到这个故事时，迪米特里斯，我仿佛看到八岁版本的你就在我们眼前变成了一名人类学家，观察着周围所有人，并询问他们为什么要这样做。但事实也是，你不仅成为了这项运动的球迷，也成为了这支特定球队的球迷。看，大多数人他们在八岁时出现在寺庙里，并不是因为他们内心有一种渴望去崇拜
Typically their their parents take them But it is through the act of participation itself that one becomes religious or becomes a fan, that one gets bonded with this group of people. Because when people come together and they engage in all those kinds of ecstatic rituals, this conglomeration of individuals ceases to be that, and suddenly it becomes one unified group. And even from the perspective of an eight-year-old looking at this group, that's exactly what it seemed like. It seems to be 45,000 individuals,
通常是他们的父母带他们去的。但正是通过参与的行为本身，一个人才成为了信徒或球迷，一个人才与这群人建立了联系。因为当人们聚集在一起并参与所有这些狂热的仪式时，这个由个人组成的集合体就不再是那样了，突然之间它变成了一个统一的群体。即使从一个八岁孩子的视角来看待这个群体，这完全就是它看起来的样子。它似乎是45,000个个体，
and it was simply one large pulsating unity that was chanting and it was jumping up and down together as if it was a single organism, and I was part and it was jumping up and down together as if it was a single organism. And I was part of it. When we come back, the psychology of how and why rituals affect us so deeply. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. At the University of Connecticut, anthropologist Dimitris Zikalatas has found that rituals exact significant costs in time, money, even pain and suffering from the people who practice them.
而是一个巨大的、跳动的整体，它一起歌唱，一起上下跳跃，就像一个单一的有机体，而我是其中的一部分。而它一起歌唱，一起上下跳跃，就像一个单一的有机体，而我是其中的一部分。稍后我们将探讨仪式如何以及为什么如此深刻地影响我们的心理。你正在收听的是《隐藏的脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。在康涅狄格大学（University of Connecticut），人类学家迪米特里斯·齐卡拉塔斯发现，仪式从践行它们的人身上索取了时间、金钱甚至痛苦和折磨方面的重大代价。
Irrational economists might say it would make more sense for people to make sacrifices for activities that improve their lives in some tangible way. But everywhere and in every age, including our own, people divert significant attention to seemingly ceremonial activities. attention to seemingly ceremonial activities. Dimitris, you call this the ritual paradox. From the outside, rituals seem pointless and yet they're experienced by participants as something truly vital. In your book, Ritual, How Seemingly Senseless Acts Make Life Worth Living, you say that it's a mistake to think of rituals as primarily being about what we do in the outside world, the real purpose of rituals is for us to hack into our own inner worlds? Absolutely.
不理性的经济学家可能会说，人们为那些以某种有形方式改善生活的活动做出牺牲会更有意义。但在各地和各个时代，包括我们自己的时代，人们将大量的注意力转移到了看似程式化的活动上。将注意力转移到看似程式化的活动上。迪米特里斯，你称之为仪式悖论。从外部来看，仪式似乎毫无意义，然而参与者却将其体验为真正至关重要的事情。在你的书《仪式：看似无意义的行为如何让生活变得有价值》（Ritual, How Seemingly Senseless Acts Make Life Worth Living）中，你提到认为仪式主要是关于我们在外部世界所做的事情是一个错误，仪式的真正目的是让我们深入我们自己的内心世界？完全正确。
And the idea is that just because ritual does not have any immediate direct effects on the physical world, this does not mean that it has no impact at all. In fact, it has a huge impact on our internal world, the way we perceive ourselves, the way we feel, the way we connect with other people, and ultimately our well-being and our quality of life. So one immediate question is why we need to do this, because after all we are capable of introspection, we're capable of reflection. There are a lot of ways that we can talk to our internal selves. What is it about the challenges we face in life
这个想法是，仅仅因为仪式对物理世界没有直接的即时影响，并不意味着它毫无影响。事实上，它对我们的内心世界、我们看待自己的方式、我们的感受方式、我们与他人连接的方式，以及最终对我们的幸福感和生活质量，都有着巨大的影响。因此，一个直接的问题是，为什么我们需要这样做，因为毕竟我们有内省的能力，我们有反思的能力。我们有很多方法可以与内心对话。那么，我们在生活中面临的挑战究竟是什么呢？
that prompt us to do things on the outside, things like walking across a bed of fire to change what's happening inside our own minds? Well, the simple answer here could be because it simply works. Sometimes we don't really have to understand that a particular behavior helps us reduce anxiety or cope with grief or connect with other people,
促使我们在外部做一些事情，比如走过火床来改变我们内心正在发生的事情？好吧，这里简单的答案可能是因为这真的有效。有时我们不一定要真正理解某种特定的行为如何帮助我们减轻焦虑、应对悲伤或与他人建立联系，
but visually it does so. So when we go out and we dance and sing with our friends, we don't stop to ask the question, why are we doing this? Isn't dancing pointless? And yet there's a fundamental function to acts like dancing or singing or celebrating or performing any kind of ritual together. One of the really interesting ideas that you and others explore is that there is something of a mismatch between the minds that have been handed down to us by evolution, our physical brain, and the challenges that we're
但从直观上看，它确实起到了这样的作用。所以当我们和朋友们一起出去跳舞、唱歌时，我们不会停下来问：我们为什么要这样做？跳舞难道不是毫无意义吗？然而，像跳舞、唱歌、庆祝或一起进行任何形式的仪式这样的行为，都有着基础的功能。你和其他人探讨过一个非常有趣的观点，那就是由进化传给我们的心灵（即我们的物理大脑）与我们在现实世界中
often called to address in the actual world. And I'm not a fan of the idea that the brain is like a computer, because the metaphor is not exact. But if you were to think about the brain as a computer, it's almost as if this computer was designed to solve a set of problems, but the problems have now changed in some dramatic way. And we have a software patch that can essentially get this older computer to function in this newer environment. Is that the connection that you would make with rituals, that rituals in some ways are functioning like a software patch? Yes, that's a good analogy, I think. And one example would be the way we handle stress and anxiety. Stress is a useful thing. It's an adaptive response. It motivates our behavior.
通常需要应对的挑战之间，存在某种不匹配。我不喜欢把大脑比作计算机的这种观点，因为这种隐喻并不完全准确。但如果你把大脑想象成一台计算机，这就好像这台计算机原本是为了解决一组问题而设计的，但现在这些问题发生了某种戏剧性的变化。而我们有一个软件补丁，本质上可以让这台老旧的计算机在这个更新的环境中运转。你会把仪式与此联系起来吗？也就是说，在某种程度上，仪式的作用就像一个软件补丁？是的，我认为这是一个很好的类比。其中一个例子就是我们处理压力和焦虑的方式。压力是一件好事。它是一种适应性反应。它能激励我们的行为。
It motivates us to seek solutions, to avoid certain things that are stressful to us. But in the modern context, we see that levels of anxiety are higher than ever. That's because our environment has changed, not our biology. We're living a life that is way faster than anything our ancestors would have experienced. We're living in social contexts where most of us, or many of us at least, live very far away, removed from our social support networks, our family, our best friends, we move around, we live with anonymous strangers, and all that can be very stressful.
它激励我们去寻找解决方案，去避开那些给我们带来压力的特定事物。但在现代背景下，我们发现焦虑水平比以往任何时候都要高。那是因为我们的环境变了，而不是我们的生物学属性变了。我们过着的生活比祖先经历过的任何事情都要快得多。我们生活在这样一种社会环境中：我们大多数人，或者至少其中许多人，住得很远，远离了我们的社会支持网络、家人和最好的朋友；我们四处搬迁，与匿名的陌生人生活在一起，所有这些都会带来巨大的压力。
So by finding ways of soothing these kinds of anxieties and these kinds of pressures, we might be able to solve these new problems that our biology has not had time to solve. This is an old idea that goes all the way back to an anthropologist called Bronislaw Malinowski. Malinowski noticed that in the Trobriand Islands in the Pacific Ocean where he was doing his fieldwork, the local fishermen would perform a lot of rituals before going out to fish in the open sea, but not before going out to fish in the shallow waters of the lagoon. Now he surmised that this was because fishing in the ocean is dangerous, it's stressful,
因此，通过找到安抚这些焦虑和压力的方法，我们或许能够解决这些我们的生物学属性还来不及解决的新问题。这是一个古老的观点，可以追溯到人类学家布罗尼斯拉夫·马凌诺斯基（Bronislaw Malinowski）。马凌诺斯基注意到，在他进行田野调查的太平洋特罗布里恩群岛（Trobriand Islands）上，当地渔民在出海到开阔水域捕鱼之前会举行许多仪式，但在潟湖的浅水区捕鱼之前则不会。现在他推测，这是因为在海洋中捕鱼是危险的、有压力的，
and it's uncertain. You never know what you're going to catch. You never know if you're even going to come back alive, if you have to battle the waves and hunt sharks and whales. And this is a theory that has been taught to anthropologist students for about a century, but there was very little evidence to support it. Within the last couple of decades, we now have tangible evidence that ritual actually helps alleviate anxiety. One of these studies took place on the Indian Ocean island of Mauritius. Tell me about that experiment, Dimitris, and what you found.
而且是不确定的。你永远不知道自己会捕获什么。你甚至不知道自己是否还能活着回来，是否必须与海浪搏斗并猎捕鲨鱼和鲸鱼。这个理论被教授给人类学学生已经有一个世纪左右了，但支持它的证据却很少。在过去的几十年里，我们现在有了切实的证据表明仪式实际上确实有助于缓解焦虑。其中一项研究发生在印度洋的毛里求斯岛上。迪米特里斯，能跟我讲讲那个实验以及你们发现了什么吗？
For this study, we went into a small fishing village, and there's a Hindu temple there. The local women will visit this temple frequently, and they will perform these prayers. They consist of repetitive movements performed in front of several statues of the Hindu pantheon. And before going in there, we used an anxiety-inducing technique. So we asked them to to think about natural disasters like cyclones and floods. And this is very salient to this island because it's very often threatened by such natural disasters. And then we allowed them to do their rituals in their normal way. And we also had a control group who went into a secular space and spent the equivalent amount of time just sitting down.
为了这项研究，我们进入了一个小渔村，那里有一座印度教寺庙。当地妇女会经常光顾这座寺庙，并进行这些祈祷。它们由在印度教万神殿的多尊雕像前进行的重复动作组成。在她们进入之前，我们使用了一种诱发焦虑的技术。所以我们要求她们思考自然灾害，如气旋和洪水。这对这个岛屿来说非常重要，因为它经常受到此类自然灾害的威胁。然后我们允许她们以正常的方式进行仪式。我们还有一个对照组，他们进入一个世俗空间，花等量的时间只是坐着。
And afterwards, we measured their anxiety levels, both in terms of how they perceived their anxiety and in terms of what their body said. We measured heart rate variability, which is an indication of our body's ability to cope with stress. And we found that performing this ritual actually helped people reduce their anxiety more than those in the control group. I'm wondering how this actually works inside our minds, Dimitris. How is it that rituals can actually soothe people's anxiety? What is it that they are doing, do you think?
随后，我们测量了她们的焦虑水平，既包括她们对自身焦虑的感知，也包括她们身体的反应。我们测量了心率变异性，这是衡量身体应对压力能力的一个指标。我们发现，进行这种仪式实际上比对照组的人更能帮助人们减轻焦虑。迪米特里斯，我想知道这在我们的内心究竟是如何起作用的？仪式究竟是如何安抚人们的焦虑的？你认为他们在做什么？
So the idea that my colleagues and I are proposing here is related to the way our brain works. Our brain is not just a computational machine, it's a predictive machine. It makes active inferences about the state of the world. Our brain does this in all kinds of contexts and all the time. This is a very useful cognitive architecture to have, of course. But one byproduct of that architecture, one side effect, is that when there's uncertainty in the world where we cannot make accurate predictions, we experience anxiety. And we think this is exactly where ritual comes in. Because if ritual is anything, it is structure. It is predictability. When I engage in a ritual, I know exactly what to do.
因此，我和同事们在这里提出的观点与我们大脑的工作方式有关。我们的大脑不仅仅是一台计算机器，它是一台预测机器。它对世界的状态进行主动推断。我们的大脑在各种背景下一直都在这样做。当然，拥有这样一种非常有用的认知架构。但这种架构的一个副产品、一个副作用是，当世界上存在我们无法做出准确预测的不确定性时，我们就会感到焦虑。我们认为这正是仪式发挥作用的地方。因为如果说仪式有什么特点的话，那就是结构。它是可预测性。当我参与一项仪式时，我确切地知道该做什么。
I know exactly when to do it and how. And this gives my brain a sense of control. And at the end of the day, it doesn't matter whether this sense of control is real or illusory, as long as it has tangible effects. And we do see that it does. There's been research showing that performing rituals doesn't just make people feel better, it can actually lead to better outcomes. One study investigated the effect of a made-up ritual on people's performance in a stressful
我确切地知道何时以及如何去做。这给了我的大脑一种掌控感。归根结底，这种掌控感是真实的还是虚幻的并不重要，只要它能产生切实的效果。而我们确实看到它做到了。研究表明，进行仪式不仅能让人感觉更好，实际上还能带来更好的结果。一项研究调查了一种虚构的仪式对人们在压力活动中的表现的影响。
activity. Can you tell me what that study found, Dimitris? Yes, this was a study performed by Alison Brooks, who asked people to prepare in order to engage in a series of stressful tasks. Those were tasks like taking a maths test or participating in a public karaoke competition. So the researchers asked participants either perform an artificial ritual which resembled a magical spell or perform no ritual. The ritual was consistent in drawing a picture of how they're feeling right now and then sprinkling salt on the picture, counting up to five, and then ritually destroying the paper. What they found was
迪米特里斯，你能告诉我们那项研究发现了什么吗？是的，这是一项由艾莉森·布鲁克斯（Alison Brooks）开展的研究，她要求人们为一系列充满压力的任务做准备。这些任务包括参加数学考试或参加公共卡拉OK比赛。因此，研究人员要求参与者要么执行一种类似于魔法咒语的人造仪式，要么不执行任何仪式。该仪式的流程是一致的：画一幅画来表达他们此刻的感受，然后在画上撒盐，数到五，最后以仪式化的方式毁掉这张纸。他们发现的是
that performing this type of ritual helped people actually perform better. So they evaluated the karaoke performances or the mathematical tests and they saw that people were able to perform better and of course not through some kind of magical causation. When they looked at the mediating factors, they found that it was through the reduction of anxiety and an increased sense of control that they were able to improve their performance. So we've looked at different ways in which rituals might help us address questions of uncertainty, questions of stress.
进行这种类型的仪式实际上有助于人们表现得更好。因此，他们评估了卡拉OK表演或数学测试，发现人们能够表现得更好，当然，这并不是通过某种神奇的因果关系。当他们观察中介因素时，他们发现正是通过减轻焦虑感和增强掌控感，人们才得以提高自己的表现。因此，我们探讨了仪式可能帮助我们解决不确定性和压力问题的一些不同方式。
Another problem of living that rituals address is the pain of loss and grief. Dimitris, can you help us understand why there are so many rituals associated with death and dying? Every human society we've known has had elaborate burial rituals. Now, why is that? Well, this again has to do with the way our brain works. We are hyper-social animals.
生活中的另一个问题是仪式所解决的失落与悲伤之痛。迪米特里斯，你能帮我们理解为什么会有这么多与死亡和垂死相关的仪式吗？我们所知的每一个人类社会都有精细的埋葬仪式。这是为什么呢？嗯，这再次与我们大脑的工作方式有关。我们是超级社会化的动物。
And as hyper-social animals, we have a number of particularly strong forms of attachment. We see, for example, when young children are separated from their parents, they experience what we call separation anxiety. When lovers experience a breakup, they might go through this very painful period. And when we look at it from this perspective, we realize that the capacity to grieve may have stemmed from evolutionary adaptations, but grief itself is not adaptive. There's an obvious benefit to the child who experiences anxiety when separated from its mother because they can cry for help. But when
作为超级社会化的动物，我们有许多特别强烈的依恋形式。例如，我们看到，当幼小的孩子与父母分开时，他们会经历我们所说的分离焦虑。当恋人经历分手时，他们可能会经历这段非常痛苦的时期。当我们从这个角度来看待它时，我们意识到悲伤的能力可能是源于进化的适应，但悲伤本身并不是适应性的。对于与母亲分离而产生焦虑的孩子来说，有一个明显的好处，因为他们可以哭喊求助。但是当
we lose somebody because they're no longer with us, there's not much else we can do. So from that perspective, grief is not necessarily very adaptive. And to be able to cope with these debilitating emotions, such as the experience of loss and the fear of our own mortality, every human culture has developed a set of rituals. And what do you think these rituals are doing? I mean, is it the case that they're actually ameliorating our grief, channeling our grief in a new direction? What do you think the rituals are accomplishing here? They can make the process of separation from the deceased a little bit more gradual. So
我们失去某人，因为他们不在我们身边时，我们能做的事情就不多了。从这个角度来看，悲伤不一定是非常具有适应性的。为了能够应对这些削弱意志的情绪，例如失落的体验和对自身死亡的恐惧，每一种人类文化都发展出了一套仪式。你认为这些仪式在做什么？我的意思是，它们是否真的在减轻我们的悲伤，将我们的悲伤引导到一个新的方向？你认为仪式在这里实现了什么？它们可以使与死者分离的过程变得更加渐进一些。所以
they give us time to digest the fact that they're no longer with us. And if you look at burial customs throughout the world, you will see that a lot of those customs, they involve keeping the deceased in the house for one day, three days, a week, in the case of some tribes, even for a year. Another thing they do is that they help keep the deceased alive in our memories. So they now turn them into ancestors, they turn them into beings with which we will interact in
它们给我们时间来消化他们已经不在我们身边的事实。如果你看看世界各地的埋葬习俗，你会发现许多习俗包括将死者放在屋里一天、三天、一周，在某些部落的情况下甚至是一年。它们做的另一件事是，它们帮助死者活在我们的记忆中。所以它们现在把死者变成了祖先，把他们变成了我们将会在未来再次互动的存在——通过这些周期性的仪式，我们将为他们供奉，因此它们给人一种感觉，即他们仍然和我们在一起，只是换了一种不同的方式。因此，我们研究了仪式在管理焦虑和管理悲伤方面非常有用的两个领域。生活的第三个问题与生活在群体中所带来的挑战有关，即让人与人之间相互协调和合作，特别是正如你所指出的，在现代社会中，大量的人生活在陌生人中间，仪式如何帮助我们迎接这一挑战，迪米特里斯？这也许对我们来说是所有挑战中最大的一次，因为我们是一个社会性物种，但
the future again through these periodic rituals, we will make offerings for them, and therefore they provide a sense that they're still with us just in some different way. So we've looked at two areas where rituals can be very helpful in managing anxiety and in managing grief. A third problem of living has to do with the challenges that come from living in groups, getting people to coordinate and cooperate with each other, especially as you point out, in modern societies where large numbers of people are living among strangers, how do rituals help us rise to this challenge, Dimitris? This is perhaps the biggest of all challenges for us because we are a social species, but
再一次，我们现在生活在截然不同的环境中。所以现在我们生活在由匿名陌生人组成的非常庞大的社会中，合作永远是一个问题。这就是为什么我们比任何其他动物都有更多的集体仪式，目的是为了让人与人之间感到更多的联结并进行合作。例如，集体仪式可能会让人们穿相似的衣服。研究表明，当人们看起来相似时，我们的大脑会推断他们确实相似，因为在自然界中，长得像我们的人更有可能是我们的亲戚。另一种方法是调整我们的动作，以便我们同步移动，我们
once again, we now live in conditions that are very different. So now we live in these very large societies of anonymous strangers, and cooperation is always going to be a problem. And this is why we have more collective rituals than any other animal, in order to get people to to feel more bonded and cooperate. For example, collective rituals might have people dress in similar ways. There are studies that show that when people appear to be similar, our brain makes inferences that they are indeed similar because also in nature people who look like us they're more likely to be our relatives. Another way is to align our movements so we move in synchrony, we
同步吟唱，同样有研究表明，同步移动的人会觉得彼此更亲近，他们会更有默契，也更喜欢彼此。另一种方法是调整我们的情绪。当我们有相同的感受时，同样地，我们会觉得联系更紧密。因为你会和哪些人有相同的感受？你会和哪些人一起哀悼、一起欢笑、一起哭泣？通常，那些是你的家人和挚友。通过让匿名的陌生人一起做这些事情，仪式可以创造这种
chant in synchrony and again there are studies that show that people who move in synchrony they feel closer to each other, they are more rapport and they like each other more. Another way is to align our emotions. When we feel the same thing, again, we feel more connected. Because who are the people that you feel the same things with? Who are the people that you will mourn with and you will laugh and you will cry with? Typically, those are members of your family and your close friends. And by getting anonymous strangers to do those things together, rituals can create this sense
社群感和相似感。因此，我们探讨了仪式可以产生社会效益的几种方式，但任何强大的心理力量，如果强大到足以让人走过燃烧的煤炭，也可能会带来不好的结果。我想请你听听CBS新闻关于加州一名学生死亡的新闻报道。早上好。诺亚·多明戈（Noah Domingo）的血液酒精浓度
of community and likeness. So we've looked at several ways in which rituals can produce social good, but any psychological force that is powerful enough to get people to walk over burning coals can also have bad outcomes. I want you to listen to this news report from CBS News about a student's death in California. Good morning. Noah Domingo's blood alcohol level
超过了法定限制的四倍。这位加州大学尔湾分校（UC Irvine）的大一新生被发现毫无反应地躺在我身后的一所房子里，时间是在一月份的一次派对之后。他的父亲说，诺亚当时正在参与一项危险且长期存在的兄弟会仪式，诺亚被迫大口喝下所谓的“家族饮品”，以便成为他兄弟会“大哥”家族的一员。迪米特里斯，谈谈
was more than four times the legal limit. The UC Irvine freshman was found unresponsive in the house behind me after a party in January. His father says Noah was taking part in a dangerous and long-standing fraternity ritual where Noah was compelled to guzzle a so-called family drink to become part of his big brother's family. Demetrius, talk about the connection
仪式的联结力量与我们在大学兄弟会中看到的入会仪式之间的联系。因此，这些类型的仪式，即非常激进的仪式，确实带来了巨大的风险。而这些风险必须超过其成本。因此，如果你想想这些仪式被使用的背景，例如面临更多战争的社会，
between the bonding power of rituals and the initiation rites we see at college fraternities. So these types of rituals, the very intense types of rituals, they actually do carry great risks. And these risks have to outweigh the costs. So if you think of the kinds of contexts in which these rituals would have been used, societies that face more warfare, for example,
他们有更激进的入会仪式。经历一个涉及大量痛苦和磨难的入会仪式是一回事，即使你是和你的社区长者、你的同龄人、你一起长大的所有人一起做这件事。这是一个已经进行了上千年的仪式，所以其中有很多反复试验。但当我们把这些仪式脱离背景，为了没有好的理由而进行它们，也许是为了好玩，它们就会变成完全不同的东西。将该仪式脱离背景、进行调整，并试图在完全不同的环境中利用它来获得相同的益处，这是非常不同的一回事。
they have more intense initiation rituals. And it is one thing to go through an initiation ritual that involves a lot of pain and suffering, even if you're doing this with the elders of your community, your cohort, everybody you grew up with. And that's a ritual that has been performed for a thousand years, so there's a lot of trial and error going on. But when we take those rituals out of context and we perform them for no good reason, perhaps for fun, they can become something very different. It's a very different thing to take that ritual out of context, tweak it, and try to use it to get the same benefits in an entirely different setting.
关于你的工作，令我着迷的事情之一是，近年来你开始利用技术来帮助自己理解仪式是如何运作的。你使用的技术形式之一是心率监测器。因此，利用心率监测器，你在圣佩德罗走火步行者（San Pedro Fire Walkers）活动期间收集了数据。你在心率监测器数据中发现了一些非同寻常的东西，关于当时正在发生的事情
One of the things that I find fascinating about your work is that in recent years, you've started to use technology to assist you in understanding how rituals work. And one of the forms of technology you're using are heart monitors. So using heart monitors, you've collected data during the San Pedro Fire Walkers. You found something extraordinary in the heart monitor data when it came to what was happening
在不同人的身体里，在完全相同的时间。迪米特里斯，你发现了什么？所以这个项目始于听到人们在圣佩德罗对我说的一些话。我一次又一次地听到他们说同样的话。他们说，当你走上去时，那里有3000人，但你感觉像一个人。他们会说诸如“我无法用言语表达，但有这种团结的感觉，就像我们的情绪是一致的”之类的话。这对我来说听起来很像早期人类学家
in different people's bodies at the very same time. What did you find, Dimitris? So this project started from hearing some of the things that people were telling me in San Pedro. Again and again, I heard them say the same thing. They said that when you go up there, there are 3,000 people, but you feel like one. They said things like, I cannot put it into words, they would say, but there's this feeling of togetherness, like our emotions are aligned. And this to me sounded very much like what early anthropologists
所说的话。埃米尔·涂尔干（Emil Durkheim）描述了这种集体欢腾（collective effervescence）的感觉。他将其描述为仿佛有一股电流穿过聚集在一起的一群人，将他们从一群毫无关联的个人转变为这个具有凝聚力的群体。所以我开始思考，我们究竟如何衡量这种一体感、这种我参与者描述但没有人真正展示过的难以言喻的情感一致感？所以我们做的是，我们把这些监测器
had said. Emil Durkheim described this feeling of collective effervescence. He described it as if there was this jolt of electricity running through a group of people that congregated and turning them from a group of unrelated individuals into this cohesive group. So I started thinking, how do we actually measure this feeling of oneness, this ineffable feeling of emotional alignment, and that my participants describe, but nobody has actually demonstrated? So what we did is that we put those monitors
戴在走火步行者身上，还有那些只是观看的群体成员，甚至还有作为好奇游客来到那里观看节日的毫不相关的陌生人。我们发现，在仪式期间，他们的心率开始同步到令人印象深刻的程度。事实上，在仪式期间，他们比在山坡上同步行进时更加同步（其中一些人在走火，一些人在观看，一些人在为自己的行走做准备）。我们还发现，这种效应仅适用于群体成员，因为我们还绘制了该村庄的社会网络图。所以我们知道谁与谁有亲缘关系以及达到什么程度，无论是通过血缘还是友谊。我们看到，我们实际上可以利用社会亲近度的程度来预测生理同步的程度。
on firewalkers, but also members of the group who are just watching, and even unrelated strangers who had been there just as curious tourists to watch the festival. What we found is that during the ritual, their heart rates began to synchronize to a really impressive degree. In fact, they were more synchronous during the ritual, where some of them are walking on fire, some are watching, some are preparing for their own walk. They were more synchronous during that time than the time they were marching up the hill in synchrony. But we also find that this effect only holds for group members, because we also mapped the social network of the village. So we knew who was related to whom and to what degree, whether by blood or by friendship. And we see that we can actually use the degree of social proximity
因此，这是一个根本上的社会现象。广告之后，在一个越来越理性、对带有任何迷信色彩的事物都抱有怀疑的世界里，我们该如何利用仪式的心理力量？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。人类学家迪米特里斯·齐加拉塔斯（Dimitris Zygalatas）是《仪式：看似无意义的行为如何让生命值得过》（Ritual: How Seemingly Senseless Acts Make Life Worth Living）一书的作者。
to predict the degree of physiological synchrony. So this is a fundamentally social phenomenon. When we come back, in an increasingly rational world that looks with suspicion at anything that smacks of superstition, how do we harness the psychological power of rituals? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Anthropologist Dimitris Zygalatas is the author of Ritual, How Seemingly Senseless Acts Make Life Worth Living.
他发现，在很长一段时间里，世界不同地区的人类群体独立地聚焦于仪式的基本要素，这些要素使它们在操纵我们内心的思想和感受方面发挥作用。迪米特里斯，你发现仪式总是表现出一个重要的特征，这个特征使它们区别于其他行动，你称之为因果不透明性（causal opacity）。你对这个想法有什么理解，为什么这种因果不透明性
He's found that over a very long span of time, groups of humans in different parts of the world have independently homed in on the basic elements of rituals that make them effective in manipulating our inner thoughts and feelings. Dimitris, you found that rituals always display an important characteristic, one that sets them apart from other actions, and you call this causal opacity. What do you mean by this idea, and why is such causal opacity
在仪式的表现中如此重要？这是仪式的关键特征之一。事实上，它正是仪式的定义所在。仪式是指那些必须重复执行且具有某种象征价值、被视为特殊的行为，然而它们要么没有任何具体目标，要么人们为实现目标而采取的行动与目标本身之间没有可见的联系。因此，如果我为了清洁自己而洗澡，
important in the performance of rituals? This is one of the key characteristics of ritual. In fact, it goes to the very definition of ritual. Rituals are those actions that have to be performed repeatedly and they have some symbolic value, they're treated as special, and yet they either don't have any specific goal or there's no visible connection between the actions that one undertakes to achieve a goal and the goal itself. So if I take a shower in order to cleanse myself,
这有着显而易见的实用性。但如果我进行一项净化仪式，可能涉及把泥巴抹在头发上，那么我所执行的行动与我所追求的结果之间就没有清晰的联系，没有明显的联系。这非常重要，因为凭借仪式行动
there's obvious utility to this. But if I perform a purification ritual that involves perhaps rubbing mud on my hair, there's no clear connection, there's no obvious connection between the action that I'm performing and the outcome that I'm seeking. And this is very important because by virtue of the fact that ritual actions
是任意的这一事实，这意味着它们现在可以承担任何种类的象征意义。这使它们成为非常高效的群体标志。如果我们是那个为了进行净化仪式而在头发上抹泥巴的群体，那么我们可以相当肯定没有其他群体会这样做。这使我们能够识别出那些不属于我们的人，也能识别出我们更有可能与之合作的自己群体的成员。我喜欢这个想法：在某些方面，仪式将日常行为转化到了象征的领域。因此，在某种程度上，因果不透明性可能看起来像一个漏洞，但事实上，它其实
are arbitrary, that means that they can now take any kind of symbolic meaning. And this makes them very efficient group markers. Because if we are the group that rubs mud on our hair to perform our purification rituals, then we can be fairly certain that no other group does it. And that allows us to discern those who don't belong and also to discern the members of our own group who we're more likely to cooperate with. I love this idea that in some ways rituals transform everyday actions to the realm of the symbolic. And so in some ways the causal opacity might look like a bug, but in fact, it's actually
不是漏洞，而是一个功能。完全正确。实际上有实验室研究探讨了仪式使事物变得特殊的这种能力。因此，当他们向人们展示准备不同类型的饮品时，在一种情况下，饮品是以一种相当直接的方式端上来的。在另一种情况下，它是以一种仪式化的方式端上来的。所以可能有人会向它鞠躬，或者在饮用前将它旋转三次。然后，当他们询问参与者他们更喜欢哪种饮品，当他们询问他们认为哪种饮品更好，当他们询问他们认为哪种饮品很特殊时，他们都选择了仪式化的饮品。因此，迪米特里斯，除了这种关于因果关系的不透明性之外，你还注意到仪式往往具有三个特质：
not a bug, it's a feature. Exactly. There are actually laboratory studies that have looked at this ability of ritual to make things special. So when they showed people different types of drinks being prepared, beverages, in one case the beverage was served in a pretty straight-up way. In the other condition it was served up in a ritualized way. So perhaps somebody would bow to it or turn it around three times before consuming it. And then when they asked participants which drink they would prefer, when they asked them which drink thought was better, when they asked them which drink they thought was special, they all picked the ritualized drink. So in addition to this opacity regarding cause and effect dimetries, you've noticed that rituals tend to have three qualities.
重复性、刚性和冗余性。你能解释一下这些是什么吗？因此，仪式显然涉及大量的重复。一天一次，一周一次，一月一次，一生一次，但它总是被重复的。但即使在每个特定的仪式表演中，也往往会有大量的重复。所以，有时人们会念“嗡”（OM）108遍。有些人会数念珠并连续几个小时进行重复的祈祷。所谓刚性，我们指的是仪式行动必须以特定方式进行这一事实。
Repetition, rigidity and redundancy. Can you explain what these are? So ritual obviously involves a lot of repetition. Once a day, once a week, once a month, once in a lifetime, but it's always repeated. But even within each particular ritual performance, there tends to be a lot of repetition. So, sometimes people chant OM 108 times. Some people will count the rosary and perform repetitive prayers for hours. By rigidity, we refer to the fact that ritual actions must be performed in a specific way.
实际上有研究表明，如果你试图干预并改变仪式的实践方式，人们会感到道德上的不安。这在历史上确实发生过。富兰克林·罗斯福（FDR）将感恩节提前了一周，以便延长假期让人们花更多的钱。而人们感到道德上的震惊。大多数州实际上拒绝执行它。他们称之为“弗兰克斯giving”（Franksgiving），这引起了一场骚乱。最后，第三个方面是冗余性。这指的是仪式远远超出了功能上的要求这一事实。我的意思是，可能
There are actually studies that show that if you try to intervene and change the way a ritual is practiced, people get morally upset. Now this has actually happened historically. FDR moved Thanksgiving by a week so that the holiday period could be extended and people would spend more money. And people were morally appalled. Most states actually refused to enforce it. And they refer to it as franksgiving and it caused an uproar. And finally, the third aspect is redundancy. And this refers to the fact that rituals go well beyond what is functionally required. What I mean by this is that maybe
洗手20秒就足以保持清洁。但在类似于净化仪式的活动中，相关的仪式可能会持续数小时，有时甚至数天。因此，除了仪式具有这些特征之外，你还进行过研究发现，当人们经历挫折、焦虑或压力时，他们的行为有时会自然地呈现出仪式的一些特征。请你为我解释一下这项研究，好吗？我们将人们带进实验室，
20 seconds of washing your hands would be sufficient to keep them clean. But in something like a purification ceremony, the relevant rites may go on for hours, sometimes even for days. So besides the fact that rituals have these characteristics, You've conducted studies that find that when people are experiencing setbacks or anxiety or stress, their actions sometimes naturally take on some of the characteristics of rituals. Can you explain the study for me, please? We brought people inside a laboratory,
我们想看看在该背景下诱发焦虑是否会引导他们表现出更多仪式化的行为。我们发现，我们使用动作追踪器来量化这些人的运动。随着他们根据必须执行的任务变得越来越焦虑，他们的行为自发地变得更加仪式化。所以他们开始一遍又一遍地执行相同的动作。
and we wanted to see whether inducing anxiety in that context would lead them to perform more ritualized behaviors. And what we found, we used motion trackers to quantify the movement of these people. And as they became more anxious based on a task that they had to perform, their behaviors spontaneously became more ritualized. So they started performing the same actions again and again and again.
我认为这告诉我的是，当你思考仪式是如何演变的时，很有可能是它们实际上通过这些机制演变而来：人们在压力和焦虑的时刻自然地转向其中一些系统，然后随着时间的推移，这些行为被编纂成册。这正是我认为发生的事情，仪式演变成了一种精神技术，帮助个人应对
And I think what that tells me is that when you think about how rituals evolved, it may well be that they actually evolved through these mechanisms where people were naturally turning to some of these systems in moments of stress and anxiety, and then over time, those behaviors get codified. That's exactly what I think that happened, that ritual evolved as a sort of mental technology that helped individuals cope
各种焦虑，然后被群体和文化所征用，他们将其转变成了一项非常重要的社会技术。我们之前讨论过，当人们参与仪式时，他们常常觉得自己是一个更大有机体的一部分。当你在足球场和父亲在一起时，你就是这种感觉。西班牙走火仪式上的人们也有同感。反过来也是真的吗？当人们同步做事情时，
with all kinds of anxieties and then was co-opted by groups, by cultures, who then transformed it into a very important social technology. We discussed earlier how when people are engaged in a ritual, they often feel as if they are part of a larger organism. You felt this way when you were in the soccer stadium with your dad. The people at the fire-walking ritual in Spain felt the same way. Is the reverse true as well? When people do things in synchrony,
它会改变他们的思考和感受方式吗？是的，绝对会。这就是仪式如此强大的原因之一。我们的大脑只是推断，如果我们和其他人的行动方式相同，那么我们就更像那些人，我们与那些人的默契感也更强。这已被不同的研究证明，其中一项我们在实验室中进行了，我们诱导了同步性。所以我们让人们要么成双成对地移动，要么带微小的变化。你可以把这想象成跳舞，要么和一个舞跳得好的人一起跳，要么和一个舞跳得不好的人一起跳，
does it change the way they think and feel? Yes, absolutely. And this is one of the reasons why rituals are so powerful. Our brain simply infers that if we move in the same way as other people, then we are more like those people and we feel more rapport with those people. This has been demonstrated by different studies, one of which we did in a laboratory where we induced synchrony. So we have people move either in tandem or with slight variations. You can imagine this as performing a dance, either with somebody who's a good dancer or with somebody who's a bad dancer,
有时会忘记舞步或犯错。我们发现，当人们同步移动时，他们的内啡肽水平会升高。内啡肽的释放与社会联结有关。不仅如此，我们还发现他们更喜欢彼此，他们认为自己的同伴更有合作精神，并且他们更信任彼此。我们不仅在自我报告中看到这一点，而且在信任游戏中的行为中也看到了这一点，在游戏中他们实际上必须用可以放进口袋的真金白银来信任彼此。
and sometimes forgets the steps or makes mistakes. And we found that when people moved in synchrony, their endorphin levels were elevated. sometimes forgets the steps or makes mistakes. And we found that when people moved in synchrony, their endorphin levels were elevated. Now the release of endorphins is related to social bonding. And not only that, but we found that they liked each other more, they perceived their partners to be more cooperative, and they trusted each other more. And we see this not just in the self-reports, but also in their behavior in a trust game, where they actually have to trust each other with real money that they could be putting in their pockets.
当然，这现在完全说得通了，为什么会有这么多围绕音乐和歌唱构建的仪式，尤其是在群体环境中。绝对是的。跳舞、唱歌和吟唱，这些是人类建立联系的最原始的方式。你可以在各种背景下找到它们，尤其是仪式化的背景。你所说的事情之一是，高唤醒度的仪式同时刺激我们的多种感官，这些高唤醒度的仪式可以对我们的情绪状态和记忆产生一些最强大的影响。
And of course this now makes perfect sense why you would have so many rituals built around music and chanting, especially in group settings. Absolutely. Dancing and singing and chanting, those are some of the most primordial ways of for human beings to connect. And you find them in all kinds of contexts and especially ritualized contexts. One of the things that you say is that high arousal rituals that stimulate many of our senses at the same time, that these high arousal rituals can produce some of the most powerful effects on our emotional states and memory.
迪米特里斯，你这是什么意思？它们做到这一点的方式之一是创造这些强大的情景记忆，这些记忆成为我们的自传自我的一部分，即我们作为一个人究竟是谁的意识。因此，你的一些情景记忆可能涉及你的初吻、你发现自己身处战场的那一刻，或者你的房子被烧成平地的那一刻。所以它们可能是你生命中一些最重要的时刻。
What do you mean by this, Dimitris? One way in which they do this is by creating these powerful episodic memories that become a part of our autobiographical self, the very sense of who we are as a person. So some of your episodic memories may involve your first kiss or the time you found yourself in battle or the time your house burned to the ground. So they can be some of the most important moments of your life.
这些时刻通常涉及大量的唤醒情绪。仪式通过将人们置于表现出极高唤醒度的情境中来利用这一点，并且他们是集体做到这一点的。所以当我分享同样令人兴奋的时刻时，当我与你一起哭泣，当我与你一起欢笑，当我与你一起处于危险或痛苦之中时，感觉我们本质上就像兄弟一样。当然，这带来的影响之一是，时刻越重要，
And those moments typically involve a lot of emotional arousal. Rituals use this by putting people into situations where they exhibit very high arousal and they do this collectively. So when I share the same exciting moments, when I cry with you, when I laugh with you, when I'm in danger or in pain together with you, it feels like we are essentially brothers. One of the implications of this, of course, is that the more important the moment,
仪式可能需要越盛大，以便标记那个时刻，因为当然，被精心设计以具有这种增强的仪式意义感的时刻，在我们心中会被视为更合法、更重要、情感上更显著。完全正确，这就是为什么你会看到例如国家仪式往往非常盛大。事实上，特别是那些与缺乏大众合法性的领导人相关的国家仪式，
the more extravagant the ritual might need to be in order to mark that moment, because of course, moments that are engineered to have this heightened sense of ritual significance are going to be seen as more legitimate, more important, more emotionally salient in our minds. Exactly, and this is why, for example, you see that state rituals tend to be very extravagant. And in fact, particularly state rituals that have to do with leaders who have less popular legitimization,
像国王和独裁者这样的领导人，他们往往有更精心制作、更奢华、更艳丽的仪式。这是因为这些仪式增加了他们极度需要的权威感。我想知道，迪米特里斯，你是否能跟我讲讲某个特定的夜晚，你得以第一手体验仪式的力量。你在毛里求斯进行田野调查，在一个沿海村庄住了几个星期，准备观察一年一度的走火仪式。有一天，你站在寺庙附近，注意到一些当地人在热烈讨论，
leaders like kings and dictators, they tend to have more elaborate, more lavish, more flamboyant rituals. That's because those rituals add to that sense of authority that they so desperately need. They tend to have more elaborate, more lavish, more flamboyant rituals. That's because those rituals add to that sense of authority that they so desperately need. I wonder, Dimitris, if you could tell me about one particular night when you got to experience the power of rituals firsthand. You were conducting field work in Mauritius and you'd been living in a coastal village for a number of weeks preparing to observe an annual fire walking ceremony. And one day you were standing near the temple when you noticed some of the local men engaged in lively discussion
每隔一段时间他们就会朝你的方向看，最终其中一个人，寺庙的主席，把你叫了过去。他说了什么？所以这是普拉卡斯（Prakas），当地的寺庙主席把你叫了过去。他说了什么？所以这是普拉卡斯，当地的寺庙主席。当他把我召集过去时，他说：“迪米特里斯，你和我们一起住了多久了？”我说：“几个月吧。”他说：“对的，所以你现在是我们的一员了。”我立刻知道他叫我过去不只是为了告诉我这个。我说：“嗯，我不想假装是你们的一员。我来这里是为了了解你们的传统。”他直接打断了我。他说：“好吧，那你也应该走火。”我对这个要求感到震惊
and every so often they would look in your direction and eventually one of them, the temple president, called you over. What did he say? So this was Prakas, the local temple president called you over. What did he say? So this was Prakas, the local temple president. And when he summoned me there, he said, Dimitris, you've been living with us for how long now? And I said, a couple of months. And he said, right, so you're one of us now. And I immediately knew that he just hadn't called me there to tell me that. And I said, well, I don't want to pretend to be one of you. I'm here to learn about your traditions. And he just cut me off. And he said, well, so you should also do the fire walk. And I was stunned by this
因为在我研究走火仪式的世界其他地方，这是不允许的。这是当地人专有的。人们要么祖籍在这个村庄，要么信仰这种宗教。我的第一反应是礼貌地拒绝。我说：“我不想假装是你们的一员。能够记录这个仪式对我很重要。所以那天我必须拍照和记笔记。”普拉卡斯再次打断了我。他说了一些类似这样的话：“如果上帝想让你做，你就会做。”我对此回应道：“相信我，普拉卡斯，
request because in other parts of the world where I studied fire walking rituals, this would not have been allowed. This was something only for the locals. People had either drew their ancestry from the village or were part of this religion. My first reaction was to politely decline. I said, I don't want to pretend to be one of you. It's very important for me to be able to to document this ritual. So on that day, I'll have to take pictures and take notes. And Prakash cut me off again. And he said something like, if God wants you to do it, you will do it. To which I responded, trust me, Prakash,
上帝并不想让我走火。”好吧。所以你当时戴着研究人员的帽子，看着走火仪式徐徐展开。请告诉我接下来发生了什么。我有权限进入所有走火人员所在的围场，因为我想拍照。我正通过相机镜头向外看，所以我不知道周围发生了什么。仪式本身太迷人了，以至于我完全沉浸其中。气味、火的颜色以及歌声，每个人都在高喊“Om Shakti”（唵沙克蒂），人们一个接一个地走过火堆，他们脸上的表情。在某个时刻，普拉卡斯拍了拍我的肩膀，我抬起头说：
God does not want me to walk on fire. All right. So then you're wearing your researcher hat and you're watching the fire ritual unfold. Tell me what happens next. So I had permission to be inside the enclosure where all the fire workers were because I wanted to take photos. And I was looking through my camera lens so I didn't know what was happening around me. And the ritual itself is so captivating that I was completely immersed in this. The smells and the color of the fire and the chants, everybody chanting Om Shakti, as people were crossing the fire one after the other, the emotions in their faces. And at some point, Praga tapped me on the shoulder and I looked up and I said,
“什么？”他说：“站起来。”我站了起来，他说：“转过身去。”我转过身去，意识到整个村庄都在看着我。我面向火堆，每个人都期望我走过去。迪米特里斯，你当时做了什么？那一刻，没有别的可做了。显然我不想侮辱我的主人。
what? And he said, stand up. And I stood up and he said, turn around. And I turned around and I realized that the entire village was looking at me. I was facing the fire and everybody expected me to walk across it. What did you do, Dimitris? At that point, there was nothing else to do. Obviously I did not want to insult my hosts.
在最后关头退缩也是一种羞辱。我当时唯一来得及说的话是：“请帮我拿一下相机。”然后我转过身，面对着人群。老实说，迈出第一步是非常可怕的。但一旦你做出了承诺，你的身体就会带着你走过去。你当时是一个知道煤炭温度可以从750华氏度到1500华氏度不等的人。当你踏上火堆时，这个念头一直在你脑海里吗？
It would also be humiliating to back out at that very last moment. All I had time to say was, please hold my camera. And then I turned and I faced the crowd. And to be honest, taking that first step is very scary. But once you've committed, your body just takes you across. Now you were someone who knew that the temperature of the coals could range from 750 degrees to 1500 degrees Fahrenheit. Was that going through your
当然，当你面对这样的火时，你不可能不知道你正走在一个热到足以融化金属的表面上。而且你确实能感觉到。你感觉到自己，你的脸正在被那股热浪烤焦。我见过人们走过那个火堆。我见过火星从他们的脚上飞溅开来。我想知道同样的事情是否会发生在我身上。
mind as you stepped onto the fire? Of course, when you're faced with a fire like that, you cannot be unaware of the fact that you're walking on a surface that is hot enough to melt metal. And you actually feel it. You feel yourself, your face is getting roasted by that heat. And I've seen people go across that fire. I've seen the sparks fly off their feet. I was wondering whether the same thing was going to happen to me.
当你踏上火堆时，心里是怎么想的？当然，面对那样的火，你不可能不知道自己正走在一个热得足以熔化金属的表面上。而且你真的能感觉到。你能感觉到自己，你的脸正在被那股热气炙烤。我见过有人走过那片火海。我看到火星从他们的脚上飞溅出来。我当时在想，同样的事情会不会也发生在我身上。
I have seen people get hurt through the fire-walking ritual, so the thought certainly crossed my mind. But I just took that first step and just like people had described to me, your mind is completely empty. There's nothing but you and the fire. When you're walking through the coals, you go into this mode that some researchers have called flow. And in that state, your peripheral vision almost disappears. So you don't see anyone. It's just you and the fire. But there was one step in particular where I just knew this was going to leave a blister. So there was probably something sharp under my foot and hurt, and it did leave a blister afterwards.
我见过有人在走火仪式中受伤，所以我脑海里确实闪过这个念头。但我还是迈出了第一步，就像人们之前向我描述的那样，你的脑海里一片空白。除了你和火焰，什么都没有。当你走过炭火时，你会进入一种被一些研究人员称为“心流”的状态。在这种状态下，你的周边视觉几乎消失了。所以你看不到任何人。只有你和火焰。但有一个步骤我特别清楚，当时我就知道这一定会起水泡。所以我的脚底下可能踩到了什么尖锐的东西，很疼，事后也确实起了一个水泡。
But when this adrenaline kicks in, you don't really worry about the pain. That's the last thing that you feel. What did it feel like as you got to the other side, Dimitris? The first thing that happens is that it's as if a cloud is lifted. So suddenly you're aware of your surroundings again. But what I also felt was this jolt of exhilaration that lasted not just for a few minutes, not
但当肾上腺素飙升时，你其实并不会太在意疼痛。那是你最后才会感受到的东西。迪米特里斯，当你走到另一边时，感觉是怎样的？首先发生的事情是，仿佛有一团云雾散开了。所以你突然又重新意识到了周围的环境。但我也感受到了那种强烈的兴奋感，这种感觉不仅持续了几分钟，不仅
just for a few hours, but in fact for several days. And I was amazed at all those powerful feelings and emotions that came through such a brief moment of participation. That got me wondering, if I, as an external observer, as an anthropologist, as a visitor, as a guest in this community, if I come to experience such strong emotions through this brief act of participation, how much more powerful would that be for a person who grew up in that community, for the insiders, for whom this ritual has a deep meaning connected to a thousand-year-old tradition?
仅仅持续了几个小时，事实上持续了好几天。我为所有这些强烈的感受和情感感到惊叹，它们竟然通过这样一个短暂的参与过程涌现出来。这让我不禁思考，如果我作为一个旁观者、作为一名人类学家、作为一名访客、作为这个社群的客人，通过这短暂的参与行为体验到了如此强烈的情感，那么对于一个在这个社群中长大的人、对于那些局内人来说，这种体验该会有多强大？对他们而言，这个仪式具有与千年传统相连的深远意义。
Dimitris Zygalatas is an anthropologist at the University of Connecticut. He's the author of Ritual, How Seemingly Senseless Acts Make Life Worth Living. Dmitris, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been a real pleasure. Thank you. Coming up next week, we continue our Emotions 2.0 series. We'll consider the benefits and risks of one of the most misunderstood of emotions, pride. He was a successful business person, he was supporting his family, he was getting promotions
迪米特里斯·齐加拉塔斯是康涅狄格大学的人类学家。他是《仪式：看似无意义的行为如何让生活变得有意义》一书的作者。迪米特里斯，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。这真是一段非常愉快的时光。谢谢你。在接下来的下周，我们将继续我们的“情感 2.0”系列节目。我们将探讨最常被误解的情感之一——骄傲的好处与风险。他曾经是一个成功的商人，他养家糊口，不断获得晋升
at work, but he wasn't being the person that he saw himself to be. He wasn't meeting his own goals for his identity. And that's what we all need to be, and that's what brings us pride. And I think all of us, when we're not getting that, we know it. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
但在工作中，他并没有成为他心目中的那种人。他没有达到自己对身份认同的目标。而这正是我们所有人都需要成为的，也是带给我们骄傲的东西。我想我们所有人在没有得到这一点时，心里都是清楚的。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯滕·黄、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥秋姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》执行主编。
If you love Hidden Brain and want more of the show, please consider joining our podcast subscription. It's where you'll find stories and ideas that you won't hear anywhere else. Plus, your financial support provides the fuel that drives the research, writing, and production costs involved in making the show. You can try a free 7-day trial of Hidden Brain Plus by going to support.hiddenbrain.org. Or you can also find us on Apple Podcasts at apple.co. slash hidden brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你热爱《隐藏的大脑》并希望收听更多节目，请考虑加入我们的播客订阅。在那里你会听到在其他地方听不到的故事和想法。此外，你的资金支持为制作该节目所需的调研、写作和制作成本提供了动力。你可以访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 免费试用 7 天的 Hidden Brain Plus。你也可以在 Apple Podcasts 上通过 apple.co/hiddenbrain 找到我们。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们回头见。当前这集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。